this is Joo podcast number 406 with Echo
Charles and me Joo willink good evening
Eko good evening also joining us tonight
is JP do
know what's up
y'all good evening
JP What's up uh
seal pointman lead sniper in Delta
platoon task unit Bruiser Close Quarters
and urban combat instructor at trade at
Chief training officer at Echelon front
and of course my brother JP thanks for
coming down uh we are going to talk
today about
a book well a new a new book an expanded
edition of a book A book that I wrote
called leadership strategy and tactics
Field Manual this is the second Ed dis
the new edition the Expanded Edition
that's out there and there was a time
actually when this book wasn't out yet
but someone at Echelon front had found
the file for the book on our shared
drive like where I was where I was
writing it and it shared it uh that's
when I knew that the book was going to
resonate with people because the team
was reading it and like teaching it and
using it and implementing it so that's
leadership strategy and tactics Field
Manual
it's the reason it's a field manual is
it's something that you can just refer
back to like in the military you have
field manuals and you get to a operation
that you haven't done in a long time or
you haven't done in a while you can just
go to a field manual look up okay what
am I supposed to do here or you're
having a problem with a weapon system
you can go to the field manual and
figure out what that problem is and you
can get it fixed and that's kind of the
way that I wrote this leadership
strategy and tactics Field Manual so
there you go JP what do you think of
this book I think it's great it's a
great resource and Tool I know I've used
this book many times over the years just
um you know working through some problem
that I had as just a human and um you
know it's it's I mean that like you were
just saying the Field Manual it's a
resource for you to be able to go back
to and and and look up and see what's
going on and there's be times where I'm
working through something personally or
somebody would reach out to me and say
hey I have this going on and I would use
it as a reference to what I think the
answer was and I go back I'm like all
right cool yeah I align with it and
there's other times I go back and be
like man I was my perspective was off on
this and I'd have to actually think
about it and like okay you know this is
what's in the the training manual how
was I off based on this and kind of
evaluated it but it's it's a great
resource and Tool um you because at the
end of the day leadership is a solution
to every problem that we have that's one
of the things that we teach at echon
front it's one of our core core values
and beliefs is leadership is a skill set
and Leadership is the solution so I look
at the the training manual as a tool and
a resource it's helped me with my skill
sets as a leader as an instructor and as
a member of the echelon front team but
it's also a great resource for not only
developing my skill set but finding the
answers and then broadly being able to
expand my Horizon rizon in regards to my
my thoughts on leadership and different
scenarios and understanding like hey my
perspective is flawed let me look at
this from a different perspective and
it's it's really helped I would say
probably open up uh the way I look at
things in life and um man I I can't tell
you the amount of people I have referred
to this book um I usually
have a few of these on hand I order 10
of them at a time from Amazon and just
have in my house and I give them to
people and and I mean we had a guy come
and do some maintenance uh at a new
house and some stuff and you know just
talked to him a little bit about some
stuff and went and grabed the book
signed it gave it to him I said hey you
know my boss wrote this book this is
going to help you I mean I give out this
book regularly and the reason why I give
it out is because it has value and I
know it's going to provide value to
somebody's life no matter what they have
going on in their life they will be able
to use the book and I'm excited for this
new expanded version yeah that's awesome
and that's definitely the feedback that
I get is people like yeah this is what I
this is what I have on my desk this is
what I have on my nightstand this is
what I keep in my locker like this is
the book that people can go oh what's
going on why am I thinking this way
right now what's his problem what's my
boss's problem what's my subord problem
what's my buddy's problem what's my
wife's problems what's my husband
problem why are they so messed up and
they pull out the book and they're like
oh hold on a second yeah one of my
buddies from church he you know he was
in the Air Force and now he works for
loed Martin and um and he just got a
promotion and I was talking to Brian
about some
stuff and this was the first thing I
said to he I was like hey I know you've
read extreme ownership I know you know
the
principles have you read the field
manual leadership strategy and tactics
he's like no not yet I'm like order the
book right now and then I saw him I
don't know I think maybe it was like a
week later and I brought him like a copy
of it and he had already ordered it I
think but I didn't care like hey cool
two is one one is none like or go give
it away like I didn't care if he already
had one um it's just the value that's
the value I seen this book and everybody
that's read the book they say the same
thing like man that book was was
incredible and obviously the base and
Foundation of of what we do at Aon front
is out of extreme ownership otomy
leadership and this just gives different
perspectives and ideas and and ways to
handle those problems yeah and it's very
pragmatic it literally there's sections
of this book that actually tells you
what you should say here it's like oh
you're the SC here's don't say this blah
blah blah blah say this blah blah blah
like to at least give you example of oh
yeah you're talking this way that's not
good you should do it this way that's
going to be better so it's very
pragmatic and very uh implementable is
that a word Echo Charles check with you
in Echo Charles dictionary we're a word
we're a word you know that's why I get
some leeway with your your approval over
there so I appreciate it very
implementable the book I mean whether
that's word or not I know I'm going to
start using it and you know who will
correct this Leif Babin com hot no he'll
no I mean well you know I grew up with a
speech imp pad event and sometimes I mix
up my words in all makeup words and I
have heard you makeup words
before the cool thing is well there's
two things number one I like I went to
school uh and studied Co studied English
in college right the the English
language is made up of madeup words
there's words that just get developed
out of whether it's convenience like
people blur two words together or
they're trying to describe something
that really hasn't been exist in
existence before but they know what it
means so whenever you use some weird
word that I know doesn't exist everyone
in the audience nods their head yes
because they understand what you're
talking about even though this word has
never been used before yep and it's
funny cuz sometimes I'll do it and I'll
pause or somebody will kind of look at
me and I'll just stop and be like that
wasn't a real word was it and everyone
it's funny because the position I'm on
the stage and I'm speaking to them like
people feel like they need to like back
me up on I'm like no it's okay I you
know I I make up board sometimes it's a
really cool gift to have when you speak
for a living and everyone laughs and
I've had a few people go well hey it's a
real world it's a real word now it makes
sense but Le and I were doing a workshop
one time and um he pulls me aide on
break he's like hey you keep saying this
he goes that's not an actual word did
you remember what the word
was no I feel like we talked about this
on one of the other podcasts I have like
tried to just remove it from um man
there's an actual video I was speaking
at an event and I used the word and they
had captioning of it and they typed out
the on the captioning um man I I'll I'll
think about it we have to figure that
out no it was awesome but in in in like
good true leadership form like Leif like
he just pulled me aside and he's like
hey man just he goes it's not a big deal
nobody notices he's like I'm just give
you the feedback so that you can correct
it uh if you want and I'm like well if
it's not an actual word actually want to
corrup this so your your word
Uhl implementable imp kind of sounds
like a word doesn't it ites well we're
going with it well all right I wanted to
uh jump into this book a little bit and
so so there's additional material I
added a bunch of information into this
book and I want to go into some of that
right now read this excerpt which it's
going to this is going to give you some
background on kind of the way things
develop in my head and then kind of go
out into the world a little bit uh so
I'm going to read a little one of the
new sections in the book leadership
strategy and tactics here we
go this section is called developing
leadership
instincts shortly after the release of
leadership strategy and tactics Field
Manual I was at the council an exclusive
event where several members of the
instructor staff of echelon front my
leadership consulting company were
joined by about 20 successful leaders
from around the world who work in a
broad spectrum of Industries we do these
events one or two times a year spending
3 days at a remote site in the mountains
discussing leadership issues challenges
and solutions because the group is small
we are able to drill down get very
granular and spend time on aspects of
leadership we may not have previously
explored in depth the conversations are
generally based around stories from our
Collective experiences we explain
specific situations we've been in the
problems we've faced and how we've
worked through them on the second day
during our afternoon session Leif Babin
our Co my co-author on Extreme ownership
and the dichotomy of leadership told a
combat story from our time together at
Seal Team 3 where I had made a decision
that kept our troops from getting into a
potential crisis soon after Andrew Paul
another former Seal Team 3 officer who
is now a leadership instructor deson
front told a story where my decision
allowed our seals to get out of a bad
situation
unscathed finally Jamie Cochran our
chief operating officer at Aon front
recalled a business decision I had made
that saved us a significant amount of
money and simultaneously helped our
client to me these stories reinforced
the fact that everyone on the team knew
that decision- making was The crucial F
function of leadership and that just as
we teach at echam front leadership is
the most important thing on the
battlefield in business and in
life but after this session two of the
attendees pulled me aside they wanted to
talk to me or more accurate accurately
they wanted to compliment me they retold
the stories they had just heard
emphasize the decisions I had made they
flattered me noting my decisiveness in
each situation and commending the
inherent leadership ability they thought
I was so clearly born
with I was a bit taken aback at first
but as they continued to commend my
leadership Acumen I simply nodded and
thanked them for their kind
words my ego could not have been more
delighted and as I walked back to my
cabin my ego smiled with satisfaction
and and whispered kind words into my
brain you are such an incredible leader
your leadership skills are unmatched you
truly are a great natural leader this is
what it's like to be born a
leader I almost started to believe it as
my ego like most egos is very persuasive
but it didn't last long I know my ego is
a
liar so I pushed back I knew that I had
not always been decisive I and I knew
that I had made many bad decisions as a
leader and I knew that I was absolutely
not simply born with the ability to make
consequential decisions it was something
that I had learned through trial and
error decision-making was a process I
had developed a mental checklist that
over time had become so automatic that I
was barely cognizant of it anymore so I
pulled out my notebook and reviewed the
exact steps I work through when I need
to make a decision after a few minutes
I'd written down my methodology in a
checklist that I run through over and
over again as I think through a decision
so the checklist is not a static
one-time process but is actually a loop
that I repeat over and over again an
hour later we reconvened the group and I
explained this thought process I used to
make decisions which is the backbone of
how I lead making decisions and then
steering as subtly as a situation allows
those decisions into execution is what
leadership consists of I call this
process the extreme ownership leadership
Loop While most of the components of
this checklist should certainly be
familiar from my books and podcasts
assembling them together into a
checklist protocol that guides
decision-making is something people have
found very useful it forces leaders to
continually analyze the decisions they
are making constantly considering if the
decision makes sense in a comprehensive
way that is in keeping with the
principles of extreme
ownership here are the components of the
loop
time the laws of combat leadership cover
Move simple prioritize and execute
decentralized command ego and humility
emotions
perspective Mission tactical and
strategic
relationships and then repeat these are
my primary considerations when making a
leadership
decision
so that's a a kind of an interesting
story yeah um that happened it was
actually two years ago I think at the
council that this it wasn't this past
Council it was the one before and it was
so weird the other thing that I didn't
write about was when these guys were
talking to me are you sure wasn't at the
First Council it might have been at the
First Council it at the first one okay
yeah well so it's three years ago three
years ago the other thing that after
when I got back to my cabin and I was
kind of like thinking how awesome I was
I was also you know as my ego I started
putting my ego in check I'm also like
hey wait a second if all this stuff is
just a natural capability then we can't
teach then you can't teach it and I know
I've taught it I know we've taught it
yes to thousands and thousands of people
it's not like being tall right like I
can't help you be tall Eko like you just
like you just are what you are bro
you're just going to have to deal with
it yes
sir but it's true and it's the same
thing with leadership it's leadership is
not just you're not just born with it
and and that was another component that
made me think hold on there's it was
another uh inflection point in my head
that I said hey this isn't just your ego
look at this if this if this was really
what you were born with you can't teach
it so what good are you and why have you
been able to teach this to so many
people so that's kind of where it came
from that's
awesome um before we get into the loop
we're going to go through the components
of the loop I want to make take a minute
to talk about these lines in the book it
says I explained this thought process I
use to make decisions which is the
backbone of how I lead making decisions
and then steering and it's in
parenthesis here it says as subtly as
the situation allows end parenthesis
those decisions into execution is what
leadership consists of and this is a
part it's in
parenthesis and I think a lot of people
have this not even in parenthesis that
thought's not even there this idea of of
leading as subtly as the situation
appears I often use and we often use the
phrase minimum force required right so
from a leadership perspective if you got
to be barking
orders that's a
problem it doesn't land right and what
does it mean if you have to bark at
every tell everyone what to do that's
just not good leading with the as subtly
as the situation allows with the minimum
force
required that's what we're doing that's
what we're doing and I I know so JP look
are there times when you when when you
as a leader have to step up and like
this is what we're doing and you got to
make that perfectly clear yes there are
but um you've seen me all in all kinds
of situations over the years for how
long what since
2015 no it's been since 200 or 2005 2004
2005 cuz we didn't sorry sorry 2005
April I was thinking the fourth month of
the year April see my brain April of
2005 is when I first met you that's when
you came in to be our task unit
commander and so you've seen me through
all that and then at trade and then at
eam front and you've you've seen that
this is what I do you've seen me do
things where I've had to be like hey
everyone be quiet this is what we're
doing you've seen that yeah you've also
seen
like
like looked around and be like hold on a
second we're actually doing something
that I thought I thought of but this is
actually joo's idea like two months ago
and now we're doing it he never said a
word about it you've seen all that stuff
uh as you've grown up as you've gotten
older as you've been in more and more
senior leadership positions uh H how
have you
developed more subtle leadership how
have you noticed it what part does it
play in your day-to-day life um you know
for for me it's just it's it's the
reminder uh that the indirect approach
wins and and and for
me um seeing that from you and then over
the years seeing that from Leif and Seth
and other and then just especially with
what we do at echon front like I it's
you never said the indirect approach
back when I was working for you and the
teams like you didn't use that verbiage
at least I don't remember us ever having
a conversation or me hearing you talk
about it but you did it and so it's one
of those things where that's what you
saw so you're like all right cool I
should maybe try to emulate that and I
remember you did you did pull me aside
you and one of the other senior Chiefs
that was that was running training and
you're like hey man when you're like
yelling and screaming at these guys like
I you're like I get it like I understand
why you're mad and frustrated but like
that doesn't work that doesn't work at
the level that it could work you know
and you also have to remember like these
guys are your Bros and these are your
teammates so how you talk to them and
for me that was just like oh okay like I
don't need to be yelling and screaming
at people because what we what we look
at because of movies and or like you
know coaches and teachers and people
over the years like people think like a
the the good leader a guy that's sitting
up front or the G that sitting up front
like Hey listen up I'm in charge and
everyone's like okay cool yep ekko's in
charge they're going to go run over
there but that's actually not what good
leadership is and what I've seen over
the years and I try to do is the
indirect approach and just asking
questions and asking people what they're
thinking and getting their insights and
their opinions and you know you can use
questions to guide people to to get
where they need to be where they see the
answer themselves and they're like oh
yeah that actually this is how we should
do it and and then when you've done that
with me over the years it's then it's
one of those things where it's now my
idea and I'm going to have ownership
over it and you know my wife and I we do
that with our kids and it's like hey do
you think you know boom boom boom and
they're like well you know and it's like
okay there's going to be a little bit of
push back and that's fine it's not
because they're being defiant but you're
dealing with other humans and they think
their ideas are the good way to do it
and their ego is getting evolved and so
you're just massaging that ego by saying
no I'm not I'm not saying this is a
horrible idea like what are your
thoughts if we did it this way or hey
what about this and then you slowly
guide them towards that and so the
indirect approach always wins um and
it's something that I've been trying to
be more mindful of Cody's really good at
that you know the guys that all the guys
and GS that we work at aelon front are
are good at implementing it and using it
and sometimes like it can be to the
point where like Megan and I were doing
an event the other day and it was like
this back and forth and she goes okay we
can do this for the next 40 minutes she
goes let's you know what do you think
about this I'm like like I like it let's
go and it was just yeah you know yeah
yeah the the kids thing and I just got
done with an event and I ended up with
some of the families actually from this
this group and it was interesting cuz
the kids were in the room kids probably
between the ages of let's call it seven
and maybe all the way up to like 20y old
kids so was and then the parents were in
there and they were asking me questions
and you know I was I was telling them
this I said listen the more you Empower
your kids the the better human being
you're making and you want your kids
look do you I use the old uh let your
kids brush up against the guard rail as
a failure oh your kids want to stay up
all night okay and play video games okay
cool you still have to get up in the
morning you still have to do your chores
in the morning like you can stay up all
night if you want to but that doesn't
mean you get to sleep all day that means
you function as a human being treating
your kids as adults and look I'm not
getting crazy don't go extreme with this
but oh your kids don't want to help
clean up cool they don't get to eat like
what is wrong with you like no your kids
are first of all your kids are not going
to starve to death in one day yeah and
believe me after they miss lunch CU they
didn't want to clean up they'll be
cleaning up for dinner and they'll get
to eat yeah
but just just setting up some
consequences some life consequences and
hey this is what's going on like you
know your mom is
not a slave that is here to just clean
up after you yeah and so you either help
clean up or you don't get to eat okay
whatever okay cool let's see how that
works out for you those kids get hungry
yeah we it's very rare it's very rare
that Amanda and I will actually have
have to tell our kids hey go to sleep
now very rare most of the time it's like
hey this is what time it is do you think
it's time that we start getting ready
for bed and they're like well you know
and I'm like hey like this is when you
have to get up and they do the math and
they'll be like oh yeah I need to go to
bed because there's been a few times
like we're like all right cool you want
to stay up awesome yeah you're still
waking up the next day and like having a
struggle throughout the day and you know
Amanda's really good at how she handles
that because I'm gone all the time and
so she has to deal with this all the
time without me and the way Amanda does
this indirect approach with our kids is
it's incredible that's like the old
trick with uh like oh your kid you know
is smoking a cigarette and so you make
them smoke a whole pack of cigarettes
and like crazy well in buds for me
somebody I didn't chew tobacco and
somebody brought uh chewing tobacco to
San Clemy Island which you weren't
allowed to do like and they brought like
a full month supply for probably two or
three people and they got us out on the
grinder and they started making us do
AAL bodybuilders and then the
instructors put dip like packed our
mouths full of chewing
tobacco
and yeah I was doing 8 bodybuilders and
I'd never done never done chewing
tobacco and it was absolutely freaking
horrible and disgusting I'd be puking my
brain out and I didn't puke but I never
ever had the urge to do chewing tobacco
again that's an extreme example but yeah
I uh I know I think Cody's dad made him
do that like he like I think something
along of cigarette he's like all right
cool took the filter off and made him
smoke like a full cigarette or a full
pack without the F and he's like bro I
was so sick never never again and it's
just like yeah that's
uh that's that's the powerful thing
about the indirect approach and the
other thing when you were talking
about people being in charge and like
you the The Stereotype is like oh
they're up in there telling everyone to
do when someone's a really good leader
they don't even say they never have to
say that they're in a leadership
position cuz everybody knows everybody
just knows they're not like hey Hey
listen up I'm in charge here or hey as
the CEO you know like when you hear
people say that you're like uhoh this is
a problem like there's problems there's
problems going on and if you feel
yourself wanting to say that or you
catch yourself saying just know that you
failed and the best thing that you can
do is immediately apologize say hey you
know what guys I'm
sorry I should never have to use my
position like for that yeah and then why
are you having to do that cuz you're
insecure yeah you're insecure but
there's also something wrong with your
idea
I'm JP I'm theic I'm the officer Inge
this is the plan we're going to use if I
have to do that what's wrong with my
plan because it's not like JP wants to
use a plan that sucks it's not like
you're like no I want us to get in you
know contact with the Enemy and get
killed no you're not thinking that so if
I'm saying No this is the way we're
going to do it and the only way for me
to flex that on you is to use my rank
there's something wrong with my idea
yeah so or there's something or like you
said there's nothing wrong with my ego
yeah well I and I believe those
literally feed into each other because
if I know there's something wrong with
my idea but I still want to run it I'm
insecure about my idea getting exposed
because if if we start talking about my
idea and thinking about it and you start
asking questions and expose my bad plan
it's just easier for me to impose my
authority so we just go execute it and
you're secretly hoping it works and
you're hoping your people are smart
enough to adapt and and it's just that's
the horrible I mean that's what's just
we talk about all the time like your ego
is not our ego drives us for sure but
when you can't control and subordinate
your ego that's when bad things happen
it's a problem yes problem big problem
all right um I think that covers what I
wanted to touch on there all right let's
get into this the the leadership Loop
here and starting off with this section
time time is the first thing I consider
when making a decision because it's the
one thing I have almost no control over
there is no getting back time once it is
lost time is also the key driver of the
need for many decisions whether or not
to act and how time makes some
situations get worse time makes other
situations get better this is this makes
time a double-edged sword sometimes it
helps me but sometimes it hurts me so I
need to consider what impact time will
have on my decision and its outcome some
people have an objectively good sense of
time and I'm lucky to be one of those
people I constantly hear the clock
ticking and I profoundly understand the
incessant nature of time I know that
things tend to take longer than it seems
they will I know that wasted time cannot
be recovered I know that time creates
pressure and I know what can happen when
pressure builds unchecked an explosion
so I am always so I am and always have
been acutely aware of time
contrarily some people do not have an
accurate assessment of time they don't
feel the clock ticking they are often
late late to meetings late to events
late to complete tasks and projects they
repeatedly misjudge how long things will
take estimating something will take 10
minutes when it will take an hour or
that it will take one month when it will
take three they end up in scenarios
where the clock applies the kind of
pressure that causes things to break
these leaders seldom succeed without
having people on their team who under
who do understand the impact of time
left on their own they will lose the
battle with time over and over
again go on to talk about this is
something that I learned right like I
hate the feeling of fighting against
time because you can't stop it and the
only way to to to not have that feeling
because there's no there's nothing you
can do about it there's nothing you can
do about it the only way you can
overcome that is to be ahead of it
that's why when it comes to decision-
making time is always the first thing
that I think about like do I need to
make this decision now how much time do
we have that's the first thing I think
about because once it goes it's gone
yeah that idea of the power curve I
talked about it with Dave Dave Burke
good deal Dave yeah good deal Dave Burke
it's a thing from flying right and it's
like at a certain
speed you have you have to be going a
certain speed with an aircraft in order
for that thing to fly yeah and not fall
out of the sky and your engine can also
hold you up like by applying power so
that you're moving forward enough but at
a certain point you're not going fast
enough there's not enough movement over
the wings and they call that the power
curve and if you get behind the power
curve you can't recover you
crash so you can't get behind the power
curve and I first heard that I didn't
know that it came from Aviation but in
the SEAL Teams when I was young they Ed
that expression a lot like oh you're
behind the power curve and once you get
behind the power curve bro it's like you
can't catch up it's like when you're
doing Jiu-Jitsu and you get behind the
like someone's initiating offense on you
and you're trying to C and you just all
of a sudden you're just behind and you
can't catch up you're going down I feel
triggered right now I feel like you're
exposing my Jiu-Jitsu
game trigger and and some people might
take a little bit of a uh issue with me
saying you can't control time because of
course I can say like well you know we
you know I get up early and I'm going to
get this done ahead of time and you can
you can but you're still not controlling
time that clock is still freaking
ticking you can't there's nothing you
can do to stop it like you said the only
thing you can do is try to get ahead of
it the only thing you can truly do with
time is make the most of it y it's just
understand hey this is what I have I'm
going to make the most of it and if
that's you know just understanding what
the priorities are in your life like
that's what you can do with time but you
actually can't control it and people
that get offended by that are the ones
that understand that they've been
wasting time and that they're not
willing to be disciplined enough to make
the most of that time those are the only
people that are going to get offended by
saying oh you can't control time well
I'm sorry but that's factual so yeah
wasted time
is like a sin it really is it actually
is it's in Proverbs I don't know the
exact like chapter and verse but it it's
in the Bible
like wasting time he says you lazy bones
he talks about how how ants prepare even
though like it it's going to drive me
crazy but yes it is it is a Biblical
principle so it is a sin yes it's a
waste time because think about it this
is a gift that God's giving you like
God's saying Hey I'm giving you this
time I'm giving you this opportunity go
and you're just like I don't know I'm
just going to H that's it's ridiculous
that's why one of our mindsets for
victory is default aggressive because
our natural tendency is Delayed Action
however if we're being default
aggressive making the most of the time
that we have with us like that's what we
need to be doing yeah we were on uh the
academy call the other day and the topic
on the academy call is how to stay
focused at work and we got on this
tangent where people were asking
questions like well you know you know
it was kind of funny because it's on a
call with a bunch of people that believe
in the principles of extreme ownership
yeah and everyone kind of started saying
like well you know the thing is with the
phones these days and it's the email
Chimes and they got so many and the
collective there was a collective blame
on the phone zero ownership zero
ownership and I was and and this one guy
was like you know we put apps on and I
said finally I was like hey everybody
we're all sitting here saying that the
phone is the problem not not the phone
problem it's your problem it's my
problem it's our problem and that phone
is going to keep doing what that phone
does and if you keep listening to that
phone and you keep looking at that phone
guess what's going to happen all your
time is going to be wasted that's what's
going down so don't waste any time
that's what I got I also quoted uh BC
yeah yep do it it'll be done do it it'll
be because for me one of the things that
is in for the the way my personality is
if I have to do something tomorrow like
if something is due
tomorrow I have to get it done tonight
like I won't like preparing for a
podcast if we're recording a podcast
tomorrow in the afternoon I can't go to
sleep mentally until it's ready today I
just can't there was another thing right
that you brought uh what you looming
yeah I don't like L I never forgot that
and it's true it's just another version
of dud it and it'll be done it's kind of
like they you know kind of uh related
you know in that way but that goes deep
do it and it'll be done it goes deep cuz
like the feeling I always got was be
like when it really landed be like oh
yeah it is done when you already did it
you know I'm so glad I did that big one
daily is like working out right working
out in the morning which I try to do I
try to work out before lunch I don't do
the 4:30 sometimes I do but anytime it's
early bro the feeling later like after
we record after we do the stuff you do
during the day and you're like holy C I
already did my workout I don't have to
work out best reward man such a good
reward do it be done and that's yeah
huge massive payoff BC BC all day BC all
day coming in hot all right there's in
in Ephesians Ephesians
5:15 so be careful how you live don't
live like fools but like those who are
wise verse 16 make the most of every
opportunity in these evil days don't act
thoughtlessly but understand what the
Lord wants you to do don't be drunk with
wine because that will ruin your life
instead said be filled with the Holy
Spirit singing Psalms and hymns and
spiritual songs amongst yourself and
making music to the Lord your hearts and
give thanks for everything to God the
father in the name of the Lord Jesus
Christ and then it just talks about more
like Spirit guided relationships with
wives and husbands but in Ephesians it
talks about it but I know they in
Proverbs it does talk about well yeah I
mean I got Ephesians right here don't
waste your time on useless work mere
busy work the barren Pursuits of
Darkness expose these things for the
Sham they are it's a scandal when people
it's a scandal when people waste their
lives on things they must do in the
darkness where no one else will see that
was Ephesians 51 Ephesians 511 all right
all right so we're going to have to take
this from the top and you're going to
have to read yeah read read 511 through6
okay all
right so I'm going to go uh
cool you good you got it prepped you can
actually say uh here it is yeah here it
is Ephesians um hold on all right let's
go on to the next one but before did you
did you pull up that that Biblical quote
let's he y so I'm going to find the one
from Proverbs but we found in Ephesians
51 take no part in the worthless Deeds
of evil and darkness instead expose them
it is shameful even to talk about the
things that ungodly people do in secret
but their evil intentions will be
exposed when the light shines on them
for the light makes everything visible
that is why it is said awake Oh Sleeper
rise from the dead and Christ will give
you light so be careful how you live
don't live like fools but like those who
are wise make the most of every
opportunity in these evil days don't act
thoughtless but understand what the Lord
wants you to
do here's a modern version of that
imagine
if you were being filmed and watched all
the time like uh what's this Jim Cary
movie dude TR show TR show right if the
imagine if everything that you were
doing people were watching and
judging like brother what made me think
about no what made me think about that
is if you're doing things in the
darkness right the things you do in the
darkness the things that you don't want
people to know you're doing it's
probably wasting a bunch of time
probably right yes look some of it might
just be downright freaking you shouldn't
be doing it son right downright
nefarious I found it Proverbs Proverbs
6 um oh Proverbs 6 is great but here it
is Proverbs 66 take a lesson from ants
you lazy bones learn from their ways and
become wise though they have no Prince
or Governor or ruler to make them work
they labor hard all summer Gathering
food for the winter but you lazy bones
how long will you sleep when will you
wake up a little extra sleep a little
more Slumber a little folding of the
hands to rest then poverty will pounce
on you like a bandit scarcity will
attack you like an unarmed Ro like an
armed Rock Rob ber what are worthless
and wicked people like they are constant
Liars signaling their deceit with a wink
of an eye a nudge of the foot or a
wiggle of a finger their perverted
Hearts plot evil and they constantly
stir up trouble trouble but they will be
destroyed suddenly broken in an instant
beyond all hope and healing and then it
just keeps going on I mean it's awesome
like Proverbs Proverbs is great if you
don't even know where to start in the
Bible just whatever day of the month it
is read that Proverbs today is the 29th
I'm going to read Proverbs 29 later
today
so um that right there they weren't
playing around when they wrote that one
it starts off saying like hey you should
work hard and then it's saying you're
perverted and evil like it goes straight
down right this is where it's going all
factual because that's as as humans yeah
we're F this is where it's going all
right so don't waste
time uh when making a decision going
back to the book when making a decision
consider time and ask yourself how much
time do I have when is the deadline is
there any way to buy more
time how does time impact the situation
what will happen when time runs out
there's you know again is there can I
buy more time well how do you do that
you just said you can't control time but
there's times where you can buy more
time you can push out a decision you can
make some small adjustments you can hang
on a little bit longer in the current
situ like there's things you can do to
buy more time but you just have to be
cognizant of it all right um the next
whole section is very familiar to to
those of us that that study and live by
the laws of combat leadership the first
one is cover and move and I read about
cover move in here everyone knows what
cover Move is now but when I making a
decision I need to make sure that my
decision is not going to leave any part
or parts of any team
unsupported to leave teams unsupported
is all but guaranteeing they will
fail cover and move also ensures that
the team comes first if I am making a
decision that only benefits me I am
clearly not covering the rest of my team
a good leader puts the team above
themselves the team comes first that is
the essence of cover Move making sure
that your decision allows people and
teams to support each other is critical
for
success and this is one of those things
that I think it was LEF was telling the
story he was listening I was on a
podcast with uh Jordan Peterson and Leif
I I think was LE was telling me he's
listening to it and I think Jordan asked
me like what's a good seal and he was
kind of thinking like oh what sh going
to say you know like and because we
never really talked about like what
makes a good seal and finally I said oh
you know I said it's not the best shot
it's not the fastest not the strongest
what makes someone a good seal is when
they put the team above themselves yep
when they don't leave you hanging when
they cover for you like when they cover
for the team that's what makes a good
seal it's number one law of combat
leadership and this is something that
man when I recognize this and this is
thanks to well I mean I guess Roger
Hayden uh Vietnam seal who was like he
didn't make some big deal out of it like
I was doing something and he's like we
weren't covering to moving I wasn't
covering for somebody he's like you got
to cover for that guy and I was kind of
like and for some reason it just hit me
that
oh that's that's what you're doing with
that's what this whole thing that's what
everything we do is like all of our
immediate action drills moving down the
hallway and see everything that we're
doing and ring a room everything is
based on you got to cover for your
friend that's what it's all based on
when you're going through basic SEAL
training you have a swim buddy you never
leave them no matter what happens you
support them you cover for
them so when I'm making a decision and
then it then it carries out into squads
and platoon and teams and that's the way
the world
works and then even when we're working
with the army or working at the Marine
Corp it's like oh are we doing
everything we can to make sure we don't
leave them hanging yeah I mean there's
operations that we did where it's was
like you know what we got we we got to
do this because the Army needs the
Marine Corps needs us out there only you
going to tell the Marine Corps like hey
sorry you guys can cover your own no no
we're not doing CH zero CH chance
so it's a very it's a very important
thing to consider when you're making a
decision and there's so many decisions
that you can go oh yeah I'm going to
leave JP hanging can't do it think about
that I'm going to leave JP hanging on
this situation yep I can't do I can't do
that it's not a good decision oh I'm
going to provide support to this part of
the company but not that part oh no no
that's not good we can't do that so
thinking about this
is you that's why it's high up in the in
the pecking order yeah and I think as as
humans we need to be very intentional
with implementing this into who we are
you know as you're saying this like one
of the guys that helps us out at Echelon
front regularly um Josh strawberg he
helps out with all the mustard he's
there at every mustard helping out he
helps out at every
FTX this is like as you're saying that
I'm like this is Josh now I have a lot
of friends a lot of people I could add
to this list but as you're saying I'm
like this is Josh to his core and it was
just as you're talking about this as I'm
listening and I'm
thinking he does what a lot of us as
humans need to be more mindful of is
he's very intentional about this
principle about taking care of around
all the people around us the uh uh the
men's event that I went to I've talked
to you about it called
Pursuit I've gone back and served and
Josh went through and he was serving and
part of that was he's like hey I'll pick
up people along the way that need to get
there because he just you know that's
part of like some of these guys maybe
not want to go last minute like but you
know that if I'm picking you up you're
going to be ready and so that's he was
picking these guys up and while he was
driving it was last winter when we had
some pretty bad storms in Texas he toled
his truck like a semi-truck almost hit
him he went to move out of the way it
caught ice spun out of control total his
truck so he gets towed he takes an Uber
to get a minivan rental he goes and gets
a rental vehicle and still picks up
everybody and shows up to the event
serves gets everybody dropped off back
home and then he's like all right I got
to figure out what I got to do next like
you know how many people would have just
been like I'm done man hey hey I total
my truck Echo I can't pick you up and
you would have been like all right man
okay cool everything okay but instead he
still got the job done and I I think if
if we as humans now everything on this
list we need to be intentional about
everything on the list but if we're not
one obviously the time one is I hope
very apparent but if we miss cover and
move all these other Things Fall Apart
and that's why you said it's the it's
the tactic that we use all of the time y
all of the time and I would have loved
to have put cover Move simple
prioritized next to you decentralized
command as number one I would have loved
to have done that yes here's the problem
you have to think about time first cuz
you might have time that's most
important thing that you got to handle
right now I might have time to make a
decision I might have time to decide
between what I'm going to do this or I'm
going do that so you have to think about
time first but immediately after that
it's like am I providing support for the
people around me yeah and if I'm not
doing that this is probably not a good
decision yep there's a probably there's
probably an issue with this decision
that I'm about to make and if you move
forward with that decision you are
wasting time which is the limited
resource that we don't have enough of so
so often like you like when we were
running tryad um you know a fire team
ends up on their own they're going to
die like they're just going to die if if
they lose support they're going to die
it's in the business world too oh we we
got this project going and we really
can't support this element because
they're doing this project that no one
really cares about cool you might as
well just cut them off and just put them
out of their misery because when people
are alone or when a team's unsupported
they they cannot be successful so
cover cover so people can move uh going
back to the book here when making a
decision consider cover move and ask
yourself am I putting the team before
myself are the teams able to support
each other so in a leadership position
you sometimes like I I might be saying
Ekko you do this JP you do that but I'm
putting you both in isolated
areas that's also that's a mistake you
if you look it's not necessarily I can't
cover for you but maybe you can't cover
for each other so that's a
problem and then finally is any person
team or element being left
alone so there you go cover and move
remember that next one is simple the
next check I am going to do when making
a decision is for Simplicity complexity
is a killer on the battlefield in
business and in any leadership situation
so I almost always want to choose the
simplest course of
action and this really plays a huge role
in the fact that when things go wrong
and you have a complicated plan it's
going to be 10 times worse or 50 times
worse or a thousand times
worse you you have to keep things simple
and if you're starting to Veer into a
complicated decision well there's going
to be issues yeah uh I break it down in
the book
here when making a decision consider the
complexity of the situation and ask
yourself and again I'm fast forwarding I
forgot to say this I'm fast forwarding
through a bunch of other information
here about these topics but how can I
simplify this plan is there a simpler
solution imagine that you're about to
make a decision you just ask yourself
hold on a second is there a simpler
solution I can just about guarantee you
the simpler solution is better I can
just about guarantee
you you're looking at three different
options which one is the simplest
option uh next one if this is a complex
problem how can I break it into simple
components cuz there are things in the
world that are complex we work with
companies that do some incredibly
complex
things sometimes you got to take complex
things and break them into simple
components um next one am I conveying
the plan in a simple clear concise
manner and how can I make sure my team
understands so there you go simple
yep next one prioritize and execute
Third Law of combat leadership fast
forward a little bit here trying to
solve all problems at once leads to a
lack of focus resources being spread too
thin and too many things happen happen
at the same time I do not allow that to
happen I prioritize and then execute
according to those
priorities there you go pretty
straightforward this is an easy one to
get to lose your mind on because we're
distracted you know we talked about your
phone distract your phone distracts you
right but guess what else distract you
nine different problems that you got
going on yeah and they're all pulling at
you and if you try and solve them all
it's not going to
work so get Focus together prioritize
and
execute um when deciding how to solve a
series of problems consider them all and
ask yourself what is the highest
priority problem I have is solving that
problem going to have the biggest impact
and bringing the team success you ever
seen somebody get sidetracked on a
problem that really it's a complicated
problem yeah but it's really not going
to have a huge impact yep it's like a
breacher at a door and it's a really
crazy door to get through and it's going
to take 15 minutes and meanwhile you
could have taken two steps to the left
and gone through a window in 3 seconds
yeah that happens in life bro
like I'm one of those people that will
like watch for a little bit as people
are trying to solve some big crazy
problem and then be like hey why don't
we just not do that you know what I mean
hey let's just go around that yeah let's
not let's just not engage with that
client or let's not produce that thing
you know how many times we've been going
to make something and oh my God it's
this big giant freaking problem it's
going to take so many resources and so
much effort so much time and it's like
hey I got to let's not make that that
thing which by the way was going to have
a tiny amount of Revenue which very
Niche group of people actually want and
need that thing so why are we putting
all this time and effort into something
that doesn't really matter so just
because something is a big problem
doesn't mean it's an important problem
yeah so that's why I put that in there
is solving that problem going to have
the biggest impact and bringing bringing
the team success it's a good question to
ask and then is my decision going to
focus the team's resources to get the
problem
solved so think about that from a
leadership perspective when you make a
decision on something is that decision
going to focus the team because that's
or is it going to scatterbrain them is
it going to send them in a bunch of
different direction it should be
focusing
them now I also made a note here uh
other methods
because we always talk about and the
primary methodology of prioritizing
execute is to take the biggest problem
and get that problem solved you have to
tie to that is it going to have the
biggest impact on the situation because
like I just said the biggest problem
isn't necessarily going to have the
biggest impact but there are times where
solving some of the little problems and
just getting them off the off the plate
right let's get that thing out of the
way there's times where that's a a
beneficial methodology mhm sometimes I
do that depending on what the scenario
is but I'll look at all the issues and
be like hold on a second we could get
this thing done in 15 minutes let's just
get that thing done let's get it off the
plate and then we'll have this other
thing that's going to take N9 minutes
let's get that thing done and then we'll
be able to focus 100% on this big thing
that's going to take three hours yeah um
there's a guy I know he is a a a a
billionaire with the B right legit
billionaire and one of his rules is if I
can get it done in between Less Than 3
to 5 minutes I do it right now MH it's
just boom execute get it done get it
done and it gives him the freedom to
think strategically for the bigger
problems that he knows he's going to
have to attack throughout the day and um
and then so that just reminded me of
that and I try to remind myself of that
as like hey if it can take if if this is
going to be three to five minutes like
let's just go get it done the cool thing
with you know the next law combat that
you're getting ready to talk about
decentralized command is hey can my team
be doing some of these things can I
delegate these smaller tasks that I know
my team is more than capable of getting
done so that allows me to look at these
bigger pictures more strategically which
feeds back into prioritize and execute
of like okay hey what's going to have
the biggest impact to the
overall accomplishment of the team which
feeds into cover move because then if
I'm taking care of my people my people
are number one then I know I have to get
the job done so yeah yep uh here's
something else when it comes to
priorities this is like on a daily basis
kind of
scenario thinking about doing the
long-term strategic things
first and this is a very difficult thing
to do because the easier thing to do and
what seems like the biggest thing to
focus on is what's due right now what I
got to do right now so let me give you
an
example I'm writing a book and I'm
getting ready for a podcast right so I I
have to write a certain amount of day I
got to write an hour a day right got to
write a thousand words a day cool takes
me about an hour and I've got a podcast
that I'm going to do with Echo Charles
tomorrow and I got to get a book finish
reading a book and taking the notes on
the book okay cool and then do the like
actual prep that's going to take me four
hours five hours something like
that what but the podcast is due
tomorrow yeah so that's the bigger
bigger priority right
clearly what do I do
first what do you think I do first Echo
podcast nope nope you're doing that book
you're writing I'm doing that book and
here's why I'm gonna the freaking
podcast is going to be done no matter
what it's gonna be done I'm I'm not
going to like have I ever rolled in here
Echo and been like hey bro I'm not quite
ready no like that's not happening it's
going to get done you're putting
yourself against the wall knowing that
you will perform based off of your
capabilities got it I know that I can
also like yeah you know the the podcast
is the priority for today so then guess
what now instead of taking four or five
hours to take prep that podcast I'm like
maybe I'm going to check some emails in
there maybe I'm looking at like oh like
to do some little exploration about the
freaking whatever and I start doing some
weird tangental thing and all of a
sudden it takes seven hours and then I
get done well you know I can just yeah
the book's not due for another few
months so I don't have to worry about
that I'll work extra later oh yeah you
freaking liar no you're not displine is
rude in the truth that we tell ourselves
you're a freaking liar because now it's
like 10 o'clock at night
and you're like okay yep you said you're
GNA do this no well you know actually I
need sleep too and I got to get up in
the morning got good tomorrow's leg day
like you could just running
excuses so what do I do I do the
freaking long-term thing first I do the
Strategic thing first it's kind of like
when uh when people talk about saving
money right they're like they look at
they make their budget the first thing
you're supposed to do is what they call
pay yourself but it's really pay your
future like it's put the money in
savings first right you don't say like
hey I'm going to buy that new freaking
uh uh surfboard that I wanted I'm going
to take my wife out for dinner I'm going
to make sure that whatever blah blah
blah this other crap and then whatever's
left over I'm going to put in savings
and if I don't quite have enough I'll
just double it next month which is a lie
yeah no so you don't do that you put the
long-term stuff first and you get it
done that's how you roll so just just
some of the other methodologies that you
can use with prioritize and
execute the the thing is that you have
to prioritize and execute you have to
look at what's actually happening and to
use your word of the day intentional
you've got to be intentional about what
you are going to focus on and focusing
on things in the proper order that
actually make sense is what you need to
do so there you go
um I just smiled when you said it takes
you about an hour to type right up a
thousand words cuz I I just started
doing that the other day mhm and I was
like talking about that and it's funny
it took me right at an hour for a th
words as well yep and you know what I
just I mean I'm writing right now and I
wrote a thousand words the other day and
my estimation is 750 of them were
junk they were just like I I don't even
know was like I lost my train of thought
and I was just being stupid and I was
tired and I was compling and whatever
and it's like and I was like you know
this and in my mind I was like oh you
know what you're you're not even this
isn't even worth it right now that's
what my liar yeah my little lying uh
loser self was like dude this isn't even
worth it right now I was like oh check
liar weak and then I just wrote and
that's awesome 250 words were good 250
words that didn't exist before now exist
that's good cuz I gutted through it I
hope 250 of mine are good too because it
was for my podcast not just to write for
I'm not W in a book I know someone heard
that like he no no but then as I was
talking to you like write the damn book
dang it y I don't like it when he says
that to me anyways I just thought it was
funny as like the timing and and just um
going back to like you said my word of
the day is like I had to be intentional
when I was writing like I had to be very
intentional when as I was typing up and
thinking about these things putting your
long-term goals at the top of your
priority this is the same thing when we
talk about strategic think you got to
think strategic all the time yep you
absolutely do you have to think
strategic all the time you have to do
you have to execute your long-term goals
if you're always executing on the
short-term stuff that's due today or due
tomorrow that stuff is not get you where
you want to
go
so think strategic act strategic
prioritize the Strategic things in your
life prioritize your decisions properly
when you're making a decision look at
your
priorities right so even when I'm
deciding should I do should I prep
podcast or should I write I have to I
have to think through that decision what
is the priority oh sure the immediate
priority is I got the podcast do
tomorrow the long-term strategic goal is
to complete this book which needs to
take hundreds of hours to
do so therefore I need to prioritize the
long-term goal the Strategic goal and I
do that
first that's decision-making that's why
that's in this
Loop uh next one decentralized command
to the book my goal when making a
decision whenever
possible to is to is whenever possible
to delegate that the action of solving
the problem to one of my subordinate
leaders I know if that if I take direct
charge of implementing the solution I
become directly engaged and when I am
directly engaged I am likely I am likely
too close to the problem and might have
a hard time seeing the bigger
picture
so when I'm making a decision part of my
decision- making is can I can I can
someone else on my team do this like oh
we got to take down another building we
had planned it oh okay sure I can go
take down that building I can be like
hey Squad come with me or I can be like
JP go take down the building like cool
got it the minute I go and start trying
to take down that building guess what
I'm doing I'm taking down a building now
who's looking up and out now who's
tracking the aircraft now who's tracking
the other friendly
forces so the minute that you get
focused on actually executing something
yourself you've pulled yourself down out
of the seeing the big picture so as I'm
making a decision I'm like okay can I
decentralize this can I delegate this JP
you've had some issues freaking getting
out of the weeds I remember like you're
running the entire FTX Pro program at
Echelon front and you're like setting up
the battery charges for the weapons in
your room and I was like and you're like
yeah yeah I like I like to work I like
to do the work and uh that that's that's
a good thing that's a good
characteristic to have you know I
learned to work really hard for my
parents um but I also realize that when
I'm in a leadership position if I'm
doing all the work I'm not able to lead
and I have a hard time with that um it's
funny that you just brought that up
because I literally sitting here
thinking as you're talking about like an
indicator you know so as As Leaders we
also need to be detached and thinking
and assessing ourselves we have to be
doing honest self assessments of oursel
and yesterday uh indicator to me was um
you I was texting with Justin who works
for us full-time in AAL in front he's
you know acting as an executive
assistant for me but also running the
all the logistics and the operations for
the field training exercises that we run
and and and supporting Cody and all that
stuff and him and I were just texting
about just some upcoming ftxs and stuff
that was going on and he said he was
like man I feel bad I didn't he's like
let me read through the text message
where I screw this up and I didn't Comm
communicate this to you and I said no no
no like you don't have to like I just I
I was literally talking with one of the
other guys randomly about some stuff and
then they made a comment and we just
were talking and I and him and I were
bringing it up and so for me Justin's
reaction to that told me that I'm still
a little too Hands-On with the guys in
regards to the program or I
have they still feel like they have to
feed me all this information they and
they and I just reiterated back to him
like Hey man dude I trust you 100% I
trust Cody and Danny and you guys 100%
you guys run great training this was
just more of a a casual conversation and
uh and for for me I was like okay cool
like if that was their reaction that
they should have run it through me then
then then I've actually caused a problem
that I need to fix of just resetting
expectations and and letting these guys
know like hey dude like these are by the
way and that's why I told him I'm like
hey this isn't something you got to run
past me this is more of a hey oh by the
way conversation you're just letting me
know because I still do I as a leader at
Echelon front I need to have information
as to what's going on so that I can
communicate to you and life and have
understanding for strategic reasons but
I don't need to be in in the weeds and
regards to all the decisions and and the
gear and yeah for a long time I was
super hands- on with all the gear and
literally charging all the taggers and
doing all the battle maps and flying the
Drone and doing all the those things
literally every single thing and uh and
until I had Cody and we hired Cody gy
fulltime and he started taking stuff off
my plate and Cody's a great example of a
good leader who leads up the chain of
command because he knew I was handson
not because I didn't trust him not
because I didn't think anybody else
could get it done like I did it's just
because I felt like I needed to be doing
that work and he was like Hey boom and
he would constantly just take things off
my plate and and Cody did a really good
job at leading up the chain of command
of just saying hey JP I got this like
hey I need you to be focused on getting
us more clients hey go and go and sit
and talk with the client we'll do all
this setup and prep like we don't need
you doing any of this stuff the most
important thing that you can be doing is
building the relationship with the
client so that they want follow on work
or we can get some workshops or some
ldaps from these FTX is to further grow
and expand Echelon front and so as Cody
and D and Justin and the guys have been
doing that they have a rule there's like
this internal rule on the FTX team that
I'm not allowed to do anything when I
show up to training I'm not like it's
like they're little like they've got
this like hey JP's not allowed to do
anything because they know that if I'm
able to sit and talk with a client and
build a relationship and and just listen
to what they have to say and and kind of
have a better understanding of the
issues their client that that client is
dealing with then we can modify and
tweak our scenario is to deliver greater
impact to them to further solve their
problems which at the end of the day
that's what we want we want to provide
value to our clients I can't do that if
I'm tweaking the gear and unloading the
gear or putting ice in the coolers or
you know picking up trash or taking a
trash out because it's overflowing you
know and so the culture that we have in
the FTX program is is incredible and you
know like we we just got down with a
week long of well it was a full week we
did three of them it was one- day field
training exercises that we provide eon
front so we have the two-day individuals
and now we have a one-day individual
option and it was awesome because you
know a different price point you know a
little bit cheaper than the two-day and
also it's just a commitment of one full
day with travel more people could do it
and um it was awesome to see the impact
that Cody and his program has has
created these guys and I didn't do
anything I think one time I took the
trash out just because I was like I come
on man like I'm going to go you know I
was and even then like I hear footsteps
and I guys Sprint ing after me to grab
the trash and it was a good reminder um
that you know the culture that Cody has
developed with that program is awesome
but for me it's like hey strategic
strategic strategic and you know I I
struggle with that because I was never
in that high position I was never in a
high leadership position in the military
I was at you know when we deployed to
ratti I was an E5 I was one of our
youngest guys and one of the most Junior
ranking guys and then when I was at tra
I was still an E5 and then I made E6 and
I was an E6 uh you know petty officer
first class petty officer so I was never
in that Chief Senior Chief Master Chief
role you know I was never in an officer
role so I never experienced that high
leadership position so for me to fully
detach and delegate was very hard for me
and it's it's still a struggle that I
have because my whole life it's been do
the work do the work do the work do the
work and I'm I've always been fine with
that I like that like hey you're my boss
hey just tell me what you want me to do
and I'll go do it and I would take pride
and I still take pride in like in
thinking I'm not saying I do this but
thinking that I that I'm going to work
harder than everybody else and I'm fine
with like hey you know you need me to
get this gear to an FTX cool I'll drive
18 hours straight to make sure we're
there then all the gear set up I had to
do that one time you know remember that
first one first big one and so while
that while the characteristic and trait
that my father and my mother have
instilled into me and my brother and my
sister that's a great thing there also
needs to be a balance because if I'm
always just doing the work then I'm
failing my people because I'm not
leading them and if I'm not leading my
team I'm actually failing you and life
and when I really think about that that
bothers me because I don't want to I
don't ever want to be viewed as like hey
JP like you're not actually leading your
people therefore you're failing Echelon
front yeah my my wakeup call came when I
was uh had was just become an officer
and I went from Seal Team 1 to Seal Team
2 and I'm at Seal Team 2 and um now an
assistant platoon Commander which makes
me the number two guy in the platoon
let's go and I was still like 100% like
an E5 in my head especially when it came
to working like yeah like we're going to
make happen and we were building a
pallet and as we were building this
pallet I was also like you know kind of
had the pride of ownership
you know when when it comes to building
a pallet you want that thing to be
squared away and you kind of know what
should go where and I built a million
pallets in my life and blah blah blah
and so now my platoon at Team two we're
building a pallet and I start with a
like hey get that box over here like no
push that one hey put the engines and
all of a sudden my lpo who's a great
dude unfortunately he passed away uh
Scotty Neil just freaking just a great
guy to work with and uh we had an
awesome
relationship but he just like walked
over to me and he was like Hey
sir go ahead and let me do my job and I
was like I was 100% I was like check and
I shut my mouth and I just did what he
told me to do and that was like such a
great wakeup call for me because that
was I I realized 100% thankfully I had
enough self-awareness to be like oh 100%
he's right I should not I should not be
doing this I should be working it's cool
like you get your hands dirty like you
you you you do heart ual labor yep all
day long but that's not my job and if
I'm doing this if I'm down here not I'm
just interfering with undermining him
he's the lp dude he's running he's
supposed to be and now I'm down here
freaking gonna start trying to hone in
on things that he's supposed to be
responsible for that's bad
so you hurt the people below you like
you talk about oh you want you you're
letting me in L toown never mind that
when you are micromanaging and you're
getting the weeds the people below you
in the chain of command can't develop
yeah you know when we were in task unit
Bruiser you know Le and I talk about
this all the time I could have directed
every single like planning thing like
this is what we're doing I had been
doing this for 15 years at that point
Leif and Seth were two years deep in the
teams they didn't know right but if
I would have done that all I would have
actually done would hinder their grow
and they wouldn't have become freaking
capable
leaders because I would have been done
it the whole time yeah and so that's
just terrible so not only that but what
was I doing instead well I was talking
to our commanding officer talking to the
Brigade Commander talking to the
Battalion commanders developing those
relationships figuring out what the
plans were figuring out where we're
going next figuring out what the
strategy was doing things that I
actually should be doing instead of
looking down and in and focused on
what's going on with the
platoon so
this idea of decentralized command and
putting it in your decision
Loop if you don't think about it that
way you're gonna most people are going
to drag themselves back down into what
they're used to what they're comfortable
with and what they've been doing their
whole life yeah and that's another part
of it is even if you're not a hard
worker even if you're a lazy
bones you we people have tendency to do
what we know we like well I know I know
how to build a pallet like that's I'm
comfortable with that you're like hey I
know to freaking charge the batteries on
I know how to drive 18 hours to get this
done you know how to do that it's very
comfortable like you're you're actually
awesome at that think about that you're
awesome at getting all that stuff set up
and when that happened that was like
five years ago or whatever it was a long
time ago but but even at that time I was
like yo JP's got all the battery packs
and in his room in his hotel room
charg and everything 45 minutes of sleep
that nightz I was doing everything yep
it was terrible uh but you let it
happened because actually that was the
one situation where I almost had to do
most of it because it was our very first
FTX nobody knew how to do anything I
barely knew how to do what I need to do
with the taggers cuz we just learned it
and you gave me the feedback on the next
FTX you're like hey you need to boom and
then Jamie Cochran also was like Hey on
this FTX you don't need to be going and
doing all this stuff like one of the
time I went and ran and grabbed
ice bro what the heck was I thinking
like we had a whole team of people that
could go run to the gas station and get
grab ice and and also it's important to
remember that like you just said there's
a lot of people that can go grab ice
only you can work that new scenario that
you want to put in that's to develop for
a client that you had spoken to on the
phone that was having this issue you're
the only person that can do that well
there's one person that had talked to
that client that understood their issue
and knew the scenario uh scenarios that
we had the options for and how we could
adjust there's only one person could do
that and that's you and here you are
going to get ice or whatever so don't
let that happen right the FTX is when
you guys do the one day ftxs the
individual ftxs what's the protocol for
that what does that day look like if I'm
if I'm showing up for one day what does
it look before I come and when I get
there so it it it so one day the day
before people are we do a little
check-in registration thing and then we
have uh some time allotted for like a
brief like introduction class so let me
back it up they signed up for it they
get emails sent to them and they have
videos that Cody did and we're working
on some more videos that Cody and I are
going to do where it's all the
leadership principles that we teach uson
front so we don't have to do that class
in the morning it's like hey watch this
video they understand all the principles
that we teach uson front I believe we're
working in to where they'll also have
access to some of the videos on extrem
ownership Academy so they can get
prepped on some of the courses the free
courses that we offer on on the academy
uh and then so they check in on Sunday
let's say it's a Sunday night they're
checking in in do the registration get
their swag bag that we have set up for
them all their gear uh and then we have
about an hour hour and a half of like
hey here's the weapon systems that we
use the gear and and just kind of just
working through some stuff and then in
the morning uh on the shuttle ride to it
which this was a forced Detachment for
Cody and I we ride in with the client on
the shuttle so instead of us being there
early like we normally were like getting
everything set up dude Justin Danny cowi
Jesse Josh James all those guys they are
more than capable and they have
everything set up Justin and his guys
have everything set up when we showed up
so Cody and I rode the shuttle in with
them and we literally just talked
through these principles and these
thoughts and got them ready for the day
and hey here's the purpose of the
training and we show we arrived there at
like 6:45 is we have breakfast out there
for them coffee and then boom 7:00 a.m.
we're starting and we're kicking off the
day give some brief classes on
patrolling gear prisoner handling just
some basic basic things it's not focused
on tactics we're not teaching tactics we
don't really care about your tactics you
know we have Jesse rbert who's a former
Green Beret who's a full-time Denver PD
SWAT officer who takes time from work to
come help and he's teaching some of
these classes he he literally looks like
the rock he's like I think he's bigger
than the rock oh he's definitely bigger
than the rock yeah absolutely bigger and
a legitimate badass like the rock plays
who Jesse really is in life think about
that The Rock would play who Jessie
rember really is in life which is
incredible so shout out to Denver SWAT
those guys are insane what they have to
deal with so that would be another
podcast to talk about like for sure I
didn't know this this year him and his
guys have been in
five intense hostage situations damn
five I was talking to another police
officer about that they're like you know
like getting one of those in a career is
like crazy and this is five this year so
far and we're in September so anyways
these are the guys that we bring out
that are helping with the scenarios and
teaching the classes and then boom right
into right into runs and we go we go
until like 5 5:30 and we're getting
seven eight runs in in a day so everyone
is in all different leadership positions
and it's cool because we explain to
everybody like hey everybody's not going
to be the officer in charge or the
assistant officer in charge and that's
actually a good thing that's by Design
because the most impactful position and
we always refer back to hey you listen
to joo's podcast the squad leader makes
a difference everybody will be a fire
team leader and a squad leader and
that's that position in the training
that is truly the hardest position
because you're leading up you're leading
down and you're leading across and that
for most humans is their actual real
life most people aren't that CEO
position that literally all they have to
do is most people aren't in that role
the people that come to our training are
that squad leader that fire team leader
that are trying to lead up the chain of
command they're trying to lead down the
chain of command they're trying to lead
across the chain of command with their
peers so that's where the the bulk of
our people get those positions and while
we do have some CEOs and higher
Executives that come it's really cool
because their feedback is man now I know
how my people feel now I know how my
people feel and they go back and they're
like man I've been failing my people I
need to actually drive more ownership I
need to be more intentional with my
communication and it it's a really cool
uh day of training it's the Hands-On
application of all the leadership
principles that we teach here at Echelon
front and so um yeah I mean we're
actually we have an opportunity you know
we have the muster coming up in January
and uh for muster attendees only they're
going to have the ability to attend a
full day FTX on the back end I know
we'll work out those details later dets
we have that schedule for next year
coming out as well but it's it's a great
day of training we'll also have the
two-day option and we also do this with
companies where you know we have a few
clients that are now bringing us out to
their companies to do a full day or two
or three days of all this scenario based
leadership training to help ingrain the
principles into the culture uh I'm sorry
to ingrain the culture of our principles
and extreme ownership into their
organization yeah one thing I don't know
if I've done the best job of
communicating about this program is
that this is
not this is not a physically challenging
program at all it's not intended to that
in any way we don't we don't actually
honestly we don't offer a physically we
don't offer physically challenging
training at eam front that's not what we
do maybe if someone requested us if they
wanted to do something physically
challenging we could do it but that's
just not what we do we focus on
leadership training and what happens at
the FTX isn't the stress and it is
extremely stressful yes none of that
stress comes from physical exertion NOP
literally none of it comes from physical
it and you will likely be the most
stressed you've ever ever been in your
life and you won't be you won't be
breathing hard you might be breathing a
little bit hard but that'll be from come
your because of your mentality is
panicking y it is mental stress it is
making decision everything that we're
talking about right now in a very
intense environment and what's awesome
about it is you'll be going through this
Loop in your head you'll be trying to go
through this Loop in your head you're
going to fail at it you're gonna forget
things you're G to mess things up you're
gonna be like I didn't realize I was
yeah I just made a decision I didn't
realize we left those guys hanging or I
didn't that seemed like the priority at
the time all these things that we're
talking about are going to come into
play but what's awesome is imagine if
you uh are doing Jiu-Jitsu and you're
going against uh a guy that's a high
level black belt and you're like a white
belt or a blue belt you're just getting
murdered right and then you go and you
train with somebody that doesn't know
anything the whole world slows down it
makes it easy yeah so what happens you
go in this stressful environment and the
pressure is so high that you formulate
some good habits from it but when you
put those good habits that you formed
into a normal scenario of Life bro you
are like seeing things in slow motion
yeah what I what I love about the FTX um
is it shows you who you are cuz that's
what stress does in a stressful
situation there's no hiding you can't
hide who you are it shows everybody else
who you are too exactly good and bad and
what's cool about the FTX program
that uh that we run at Echelon front and
again that stands for field training
exercise we call it the leadership
laboratory it's we call it multiple
things because we want to make sure it's
very apparent this is not a tactical
training thing this is not a physical
Beatdown type of session yeah if you
want to learn if you want to learn how
to shoot out of a car while you're tired
we'll do that we we can do it or you can
go to fieldcraft survival or you can go
to sheep dog response those guys are all
doing it those guys are our friends
those guys are awesome that's what
they're doing uh great if you want us to
do it we can do it too we also did that
stuff our whole lives yeah but that's
not what we're focused on that's not the
purpose the purpose is to learn how to
lead in order to learn how to lead you
have to learn how to think under
stressful situations in which you most
certainly will be in and it's it's the
it's the awareness that you get as a
human about how you need to be more
intentional about these things that
you're literally talking about right now
it's you will live this leadership Loop
all day long and I still always think to
the very first individual FTX that we
did that we did in Dallas you and leer
there we had the team there and I just
remember that that couple that came
through the training and I remember this
guy when you look at him he looks like a
big grizzly bear he's a diesel mechanic
awesome guy Kevin right he was there
with his wife and I just remember him
reflecting at the end of the day when we
said you know what were your takeaways
what are you going to learn from this
training and he stands up he's just this
massive
human and he he gets super emotional and
he looks at his wife and he said I'm so
sorry because I have been failing you or
you know he just goes into it and for
him he had a lot of takeaways from the
business but for this guy it was the
understanding that how he had been
failing his wife and his marriage and
their family and just to see that I
remember we're all like I was like I
couldn't look at you I couldn't make eye
contact with anybody because I was I was
going to I I'm an emotional person you
know that about me um but it was just
this awesome like wow this is an
exposure to your strengths and
weaknesses and like anything in life you
have the choice you have the choice to
take that information on board knowledge
is not power the application of
knowledge is power that's what can make
you a great leader you can have all the
knowledge in you can have all the
knowledge in the world it doesn't make
you a good leader it's when you decide
to apply these principles when you
decide to apply this leadership Loop
when you read leadership strategy and
tactics and you have that knowledge and
then you apply it that's what makes you
a good leader that's what makes you um
to have the power to help and to serve
the people around you yep there's not
physical
stress uh but there is screaming mostly
from the people that are attending not
from the instructors the PE you start
screaming at each other there's
explosions there's smoke there's gunfire
there's
Mayhem it is absolutely it happens and
we've had all kinds of there's there's a
a a couple guys two guys we were running
an FTX program and I was watching these
two guys and they were like totally
professional totally cool and I finally
started talking to him and it turns out
there from a uh very high level the
highest level Special Operations in
their country and they had traveled here
to do this FTX and I was like oh cool
and they and of course they also made
mistakes and learned but but I could
tell like these guys have been in and
they' served a lot of uh time fighting
in Afghanistan so but even those guys
had a Litany of Lessons Learned yep so
yeah there is it is stressful it's not
physical stress it's mental stress and
it will absolutely make the rest of your
leadership
life you'll seem it'll seem like things
are moving in slow motion you'll be able
to make decisions much clearer much more
effic efficiently and if you bring a
team with you or if you have us run this
at your company you're just going to get
that times however many people you put
through yeah and you're going to start
to get you're also going to get some of
that uh bonding right yeah you go
through stressful situations together
with a team
you you you become closer as a team you
start to learn about each other you
start to know each other better your
trust increases so that's the FTX
program that's decentralized command uh
and continuing on with the book here I
said when making a decision consider
decentralized command and ask yourself
should I be the one executing granular
tasks or should I be leading from an
elevated
position that's a really good question
to ask yourself can I delegate the
action connected with this
decision will this decision allow me to
detach and look up and out instead of
down and in straight up man these
principles they are
functional uh next one egoo slh humility
one of the most disruptive aspects of
our lives and our decision-making
process is ego we might think that the
ego is not strong enough to actually
cause any problems that is wrong each
one of us has an incredibly powerful ego
that can certainly impact decision
decisions in fact there are countless
military examples throughout history
where ego drove leaders to make
decisions that cost people their lives
and in some cases cost the leaders their
own
lives so if ego can lead to a decision
makers getting their troop troops and
themselves killed it can certainly lead
to bad decisions in less consequential
environments
so people make decisions that they stick
to because their ego and they destroy
their business they destroy their family
they destroy their
troops that that actually happens all
the time it's crazy to think about it's
crazy to think about that's why I bring
up people like well I wouldn't let my
ego make oh yeah okay okay okay
pal I say this in the book our egos are
addicted to
Glory they want agency they want us in
charge to use our plan to get the credit
to achieve these goals they will lie to
us reframe circumstances in unrealistic
ways and even completely ignore
reality they might dismiss information
discredit sources or paint inaccurate
pictures you ever had your ego tell you
like yeah Echo doesn't know what he's
talking about you ever had your you know
your ego's like like discredit discredit
discrediting sources around you yes
that's what your ego
does dismisses information that won't
happen like oh JP JP comes and tells me
like hey the Market's turning the other
way I'm like that's not happening this
just like my ego's just ignoring
it or paint totally inaccurate pictures
this is just
common just but your ego is like uh
Vincent Van go artist in there is that a
good example Vincent Van go he's like
the only artist I could think
of he chopped his ear off right yeah van
go chopped his ear off my ego might push
me to undermine another team in my
organization so I can
win it might make me overbearing so that
I get to be in
charge my ego might also ignore
suggestions from others so that I can
Implement my own plan it might diminish
other people's efforts so that I can
take the
credit man that ego is a evil evil
thing the ego is also this is this is an
interesting
perspective the ego is also driven by
short-term
gratification it wants to look good now
not sometime in the distant future this
means that like any addict ego can be
very challenging to reason with and is
not reliable
help from maneuvering through nuances
it's weird I never really thought about
that until I was writing this book is
that your ego is like a short-term
immediate gratification thing it's like
an addict it's it's addicted to Glory
that's what I wrote It's addicted to
Glory it's like dude you need to be you
need to be like getting this credit
right now you need full gratification
right
now that's the way that thing
works
uh and then I say to keep your ego in
check while making decisions ask
yourself what role is my ego playing in
this
decision is my ego in check what is the
root of my thought process I actually
that that that question what is the root
of my thought process I put that in
there because that's like a double tap
the first one is what is my what role is
my ego playing in this decision I'm like
well my ego's playing no
role cuz you just lied to yourself so I
had to ask another question be like
what's the root of your thought process
because you got to start thinking like
well it's not my ego so what's the root
and you start thinking wait a second you
have to like double confirm that it's
not that it's not your ego in there
here's one why am I having a hard time
agreeing with other
people isn't that interesting because if
JP and I work at the same business we
have the same company we have the same
goals we both want to take care of our
client we want to take care of our team
and we want to be a profitable
organization so we can stay in business
why are we having a hard time agreeing
on something why can't I agree with
JP just a good question to ask yourself
because does JP want the money to the
the organization to lose money nope he
doesn't want that does he not want to
take care of our team nope he doesn't
want that does he not want to take care
of our clients nope he doesn't want that
so why can't I agree with him on
something H could it be could it
be uh what you do for ego control what
did I do or do I do what do you do just
that reminder of what you're talking
about I mean this book is helped me I
mean and obviously working for you and L
for you know what's crazy is this so
this will come out next Wednesday which
will be the month of October it's been
seven years you know at the end of
October October I believe it was 20th
and 21st is was the first Muster that
you guys did that was seven years ago
right so just the uh just working for
you guys and being in this environment
has been just a good reminder
and um you know um I mean I have on my
wrist tattooed this too shall pass as a
reminder of like hey when times are bad
like TR right keep your head up they'll
get better but also when times are good
remain humble because things can quickly
change and I mean we've talked about
this on previous podcast we don't need
to dive into it but I mean 6 and a half
seven years ago I was delivering pizzas
to make ends meat and I still have my
hat from Marcos Pizza that sits in my
closet so my wife and I just bought a
new home and when I walk into my closet
my that hat is right there eye level so
I I see that every time I'm leaving for
a work trip I see that when I come home
from a work trip I see that when I'm
home and it's just I see it every single
day it's a just a good reminder that are
you going to get a Marco's Pizza tattoo
no I'm not going to get a maros pizza
tattoo
um um but yeah it was just for me it's
just like putting things you know as a
reminder I mean like the name that I
have engraved on this bracelet that's a
good reminder to stay to stay humble
because and it's a reminder of that time
that time is fleeting and so I put
little things in my life as as reminders
um but for me um you know doing doing
hard things that are going to Humble me
like a a hard workout where you're just
like okay I am I'm actually not in that
good of shape I'm not that strong I'm
not that good at Jiu-Jitsu I'm you know
just having the ability to do hard
things that remind me because fatigue
makes cowards of us all and when we're
tired and exhausted we we do stupid
things and you know fatigue makes
cowards of us all is a good reminder to
me of like hey I need if I'm not taking
care of myself and taking care of my
team and taking care of my family like
I'm G to I'm going to do stupid things
and I've done a lot of super things over
the years and I think me being able to
be detached and look and assess and and
and humble and transparent and share my
lessons with people like when I'm on
this podcast like I I would I don't know
like I think I'm pretty transparent and
just I I don't have a problem like
sharing you know the mistakes I've made
and that's well I started my own podcast
you know like it came out today and it's
you know just to share like the lessons
that I've learned in my life like
growing up and in the SEAL Teams and
working for you and life and like what
I've learned from other people it's like
and to also share the mistakes that I've
made and I think for me for me when I
share the mistakes that I've made with
others to try to help them learn those
lessons and and talk through those
things it reminds me of just what I did
that allowed me to make those mistakes
so that I don't make them again and the
the the awesome part would be to where
if somebody that I'm sharing these
lessons with uh whether it's through
Echelon front or me being on your
podcast or somebody listening to my
podcast or another podcast that I'm a
part of like if they can hear these
stories and say hey you know what JP
made this mistake in his marriage
because he violated every law of combat
he allowed complacency to creep in and
his wife served him divorce papers
because he stopped doing the things that
he was doing initially in that marriage
like if somebody can hear that story and
go man you know when's the last time I
took my wife out on a date when's the
last time I told my wife thank you for
everything that you do for our family
and I know I'm gone a lot and I know
that you because of you doing all these
things it allows me to do these things
if somebody can go do that and it saves
their marriage it's worth it if somebody
can listen L to you and I talking about
you know time is fleeting and they
realize you know what I need to be more
intentional with my time when I'm at
home with my kids and that allows them
to create a core memory that their kids
like hold on to it's worth it if
somebody can go back to their team and
say hey you know what I'm sorry I've
been way too Hands-On I've been in the
weeds and it's actually taken away from
me being able to lead you guys and I
trust you guys and I'm you know what
here's what I'm going to do move moving
forward boom boom boom and then they can
Implement something that allows them to
be more detached allows them to drive
more ownership to their people then cool
it's worth it so for me it's just
sharing it's just being open and
transparent and and just sharing the
mistakes that I've made and and trying
just help provide value to other people
and because I also remember my man life
is humbling I mean I've been where like
we had 17 cents in our bank account I've
been where I've had my bank account
negative you sent me a you sent me image
the other day and I think your balance
was Zero it was Zero like I don't even
know how you get a b a bank account to
zero so when you spend all your money
yeah yeah but it was like I don't know
it was 2000 whatever it was like 5 years
ago seven years ago I guess well now no
it wasn't five years ago it was yeah
yeah so seven or eight years ago before
we were working together you sent me
like a text of like hey bro just FYI
this is 8 years old or whatever and it
says your bank account is
0.0 that means you had to go in there
and like withdraw your last like
$17.32 you're like no I need it all
they're like sir you have to have a
minimum balance of $1 you like close the
account I need that $132 yeah so that's
a lot different than where you are now
with a brand new freaking awesome house
and
um when I think about
ego okay this is uh Echo Charles yes
Star Wars fan um I get down with some
Star Wars yeah for sure okay I love that
response you know uh you know and I I
don't know if this is like a main theory
of it but you know how I think Yoda Yoda
Yoda hell yeah Yoda says there's a
disturbance in the force or maybe
Obi-Wan Kenobi says that I think so yeah
there's a disturbance in the force
yeah for me like when
I feel there's something like doesn't
feel
right like there's some kind of
disturbance in the force oh like in you
like like oh I'm I'm something's
frustrating me or something like like
there's some disturbance in the force
right the that immediately is like oh
just I just need to go okay yep oh let's
go find this because I know what it is
the disturbance isn't the force isn't
some other problem cuz all other
problems I can handle right what's going
on oh there's a problem with this
there's a problem that okay cool the
only thing that causes the disturbance
and the force is oh your ego is involved
here this is your ego talking yeah and
one of the things I've learned from from
you over the years in your podcast and
and working for you and Le and and and
Dave I don't remember who said it and
how it was said but I started and I you
were just talking about this in the book
is not that if it's driven by my ego
because factual 100% my ego is in play
for everything that I do in my life but
how is my ego deriving this response
that's something I've been trying to be
more mindful of because I have to
recognize and I know we've talked about
this before on this podcast and on
Extreme ownership Academy sessions that
we do is my perspective is flawed I know
that because it's only my perspective
and so I have to be mindful that my ego
is coming into play and my ego is like I
got to be careful because that ego is
going to lie to me oh yeah and you know
I have to understand that my one my
perspective is flawed and then just a
asked and say okay how is my ego driving
my response and I have to detach from my
emotions that's why Detachment is a
super power and allows me to pull back
and go and get different perspectives to
see the big picture so that I can try to
respond with all that information
instead of just one little
bit oddly enough the next section and
the next topic on the leadership Loop is
emotions and I write this emotions such
as anger frustration sadness and joy can
all Impact our ability to lead and make
good
decisions ego as you just pointed out is
often the driver of our emotions
especially our negative emotions when
our egos are offended we we get angry
when our egos are impatient we get
frustrated when our egos feel lost we
get sad and that interesting yeah so
often those
things those negative I my immediate
check on negative emotions is ego I'm
like 100% I'm feeling negative about
something I'm feeling frustrated I'm
feeling impatient I'm feeling angry I'm
immediately like this is an ego that's
the first check I'm going to make and
there's a 99% chance that that that
cause of that emotion that negative
emotion is ego 99% chance 1% it's like
oh you know some freaking guy hit my car
you know in the parking lot and I'm
frustrated cuz now I got to like go get
his insurance just this a whole thing
it's just going to be a pain there don't
like any of it right just
inconvenience I don't like
inconvenience you know it's one of those
things where I'm like so when something
gets thrown at me like now I got think
of all the stuff that just got added
into your day into your life when
someone like hits you in the parking lot
and now your front quarter panel's all
bent up sure your whole there's a
whole series of things that are now
going to just be inconvenient in your
life yeah wait so you're saying your ego
doesn't play a part in that part of it
like that's the exception kind of a
thing for me yeah that's not an ego
thing like Me Like Somebody hits me in
the parking lot like let's say we we get
down with the podcast and I walk over
the parking lot and my front quarter PL
is all scraped up that's not an ego
reaction to be like oh damn it you know
like to me I I could be wrong you think
I'm wrong you're oh you think that's ego
well how is that ego but well and I
didn't come just come up with this right
now cuz at one at one point I went down
deep through ego Rabbit Hole mhm and bro
I I discovered a bunch of egos
everywhere so that is like okay so do
you and here's the questions I was
asking myself so I'm just going to ask
you so cuz I could be
wrong so okay you someone bumps into
your car quarter panel jammed up
whatever super inconvenient yep super
right yeah do you live in a world that
inconveniences don't
exist the answer you want me to be
honest with you yes sir
please my life is very mitigated when it
comes to inconveniences of course it is
hell yeah it is I can see where he's
going there okay right there I'm just
saying hey you make a good point you
know your life hell yeah so therefore
therefore in a world with inconveniences
every single day when they affect you
face it that's a problem yep you see
what I'm saying the rest of the world
you know whatever it's all you accept
that part of it right don't we but when
it happens to you it's unacceptable
sounds like ego to me I don't know I
could be wrong yeah yeah you're in there
so yeah so at the end of the day again
like and that was the question I kept
asking like okay do I believe in a world
that this never happens under any
circumstances and then it's like okay no
probably not and then you kind of you
know you go deeper and deeper and then
it always arrives at okay so I think I'm
special therefore I'm allowed to react
like
this well when you go into that mode of
yeah you're actually right yeah right um
when you go into the mode of I'm allowed
to react you know what my reaction is
it's not like I actually react in any
way I go well now I got to go and
freaking you know it's like I don't get
mad I don't yell at anybody I just kind
of carry on but uh I suppose there's a a
completely ego free world where you know
I look at that Brent quarter panel and I
say this is great I'm going to add to
the economy I'm going to get this thing
fixed some people are going to make a
little extra money yeah I get to
experience I get to exercise my patience
in the world so basically what we're
saying is good my front corner panel got
smashed good life life gives you the
opportunity to train gives me the
opportunity to be patient all that stuff
but and obviously you know that's that's
funny and everything and and I don't
think that that's kind of the
expectation for you to just automatic
and in fact you have an ego we all JP we
all have an ego just like how you just
said right it's the the key isn't to not
have an ego the key is to control your
ego sub subordinate your ego that so in
an incident or in when an incident
happens
where your ego has to be subordinated
what's it going to look like right away
like right off the bat what's it going
to look like that ego's going to at
least open its eyes at the very least
that's that feeling he's probably taking
a breath through cuz getting ready to
last ready especially if you got a good
healthy one he's ready and when he go go
right before he Springs into action as
far as Behavior goes that's what it
looks like Behavior right before that
then you can quote unquote check your
ego subordinate your ego then your
behavior will follow suit so yes quarter
panel smashed mhm and you're about to be
like damn I can't believe this happened
to me and on this day of all days you
see what I'm saying I'm bus whatever
before that goes down your ego goes it's
about to make it happen then you go
subordinate your it's okay it's okay
it's okay this happens to every way it
happens yeah you got to expect this kind
of stuff that you know and then the
eagle gets subordinated even the quarter
panel so I guess we could trace from
what you're saying basically it's not
99% of negative emotions it's 100% of
negative let's throw 99.9 01 put it this
way the only reason why you can't really
say 100 because it's like that's a bold
statement to be like there are no
exceptions ever under no circum you know
so I don't know but put it this way the
rabbit hole I went
down what was the rabbit hole just
exploration of ego yeah you know what
just came to mind as you were telling
that whole thing is there's the one of
the worst possible like
violations is is uh do you know who I am
oh yeah what you just said like the way
that leads like that would be the worst
cases like oh I go out there in my front
quarter some guy's backed into my front
quarter panel like the ultimate like
violation and my ego comes flying out
what does my ego say my ego says do you
know who I am yes sir right whenever
like a movie star says that or like a
rich person says that we just are
disgusted by him oh yeah you know if you
get caught on camera like you're a movie
star and you're trying to get into the
club or you're even something stupid
like I'm trying yeah speeding ticket
yeah the politician that's like do you
even know who I am do you know who I am
that's like the worst violation of ego
so this is going to be one of my I'm
going to try and incorporate this is I'm
going to ask myself that like when
shit's going sideways I'm going to say
do you even know who I am and I'm like
that's right you're not anybody and your
front quarter panel is no more precious
than Joe schmo's quarter panel and this
happened good you could exercise your
patience yep and look by no means is
does anyone expect you even yourself I
think anyway expect you to be literally
happy that it happened you know things
happen that make you happy out you know
right away and things happen that make
you less happy and not happy unhappy
straight oh yeah and I'm not saying I
would like it in fact I would straight
up dislike it you know straight up
dislike but at the end of the day you
know the old question like okay I I
understand you're feeling but how are
you going to behave now you see what I'm
saying yeah so this section is about
emotions though and what's interesting
is so many emotions whether it's 99%
whether it's 100% whether it's 98% so
many of them are tied to your to your
ego it's freaking actually ridiculous
and I think a lot of times like I am a
relatively like I don't get super
emotional about stuff and I think it's
cuz I am running through a little check
before I get freaking mad or before I
get angry or before I get frustrated I'm
going dude I know what this I know where
this is coming from M you don't want to
be wrong you don't want to be shown up
you don't want someone else's plan you
think you already thought you don't want
to look like all those things all those
things that's what's going on so that's
why when making a decision you go
through this checklist and you go hold
on a second am I being
emotional I I added joy into this
because you know people make dumb
decisions when they're happy right like
I've made dumb decisions where I was
super happy and stoked and like yeah
let's go ahead and buy that
thing
H yeah because you're happy you're like
oh yeah dude this is going great go
ahead order another round like that kind
of thing I've never done that
before so to avoid letting emotions
drive your decision- making ask yourself
am I being
emotional why am I feeling the way I'm
feeling is this decision based on
logic if I were a robot would I make the
same
decision so some good things to think
about from the emotional
perspective and I'm not saying you got
to be devoid of emotions in fact what
I've been saying for the last couple
years you got I say it in the book too
you got to put you got to put the
emotions in the calculus of your
decision right if you're in a if you're
in a leadership position and you know
that this decision is going to make
everyone mad you better put that in your
Calculus you can't just be like hey you
can be mad but we're not counting your
emotions in this decision that whole
team's mad now or the whole team's
frustrated now that's not a good
decision it's crazy that some leaders
they know that and they don't care
because again that goes back to the ego
thing like you've heard this before like
hey you might be
mad and that's okay but it doesn't
matter you're like wait what do you hear
what you're saying there are people that
are just and what's sad is that skill
set it's a bad skill set but that skill
set is actually been been taught because
they saw it from somebody else they saw
somebody the skill set to not to ignore
the emotions of the team yes and I'm
saying skill it's a bad skill set oh I'm
sorry let meit trait that trait that
habit is that's a bad trait that's a bad
habit that's been taught because they
saw somebody else do it and they thought
man that's man that's cool or hey I'm
going to do that one day or hey it
actually worked and and by when I say it
worked means the team went and executed
this thing they were all mad yeah yeah
because the people we think about it the
people that work for us they're good
people they're hard workers they're
smart they like to win and they want to
get the job done and those people will
do they'll they'll
they'll they'll allow that um that
environment that they'll allow that
culture for a little while yeah and and
yeah most for a little while some for a
very long time but here's the deal like
if if you
thought that the best way for you to
provide for your family family was to
stay in the current let's just say you
had a regular job and you're the average
person and you have this good job it
provides for your family you know it has
some stability are you going to tolerate
bad leadership
yes most most 100% people will tolerate
bad leadership because what's more
important to them is their family and
they'll go endure that now they will be
keeping their ear open for another job
they W put resume out there 100%
absolutely I agree not arguing that at
all but there's a lot of people out
there that just tolerate bad leadership
and a hostile work environment because
they want to take care of their family
but as soon as that good environment and
that good opportunity comes up boom gone
done because they have no loyalty guess
what their loyalty is to their family
and if they can be happier and be in a
better environment bye and by the way
who performs better as a
team so if I make my team do something
and they're mad about it and I don't
address it cuz look my team can be
frustrated and mad and I go Hey listen I
understand why you're frustrated here's
why I had to make this decision I know
it's going to be a real shock to our
system in the short term for the next
three weeks while we work through this
it's going to be long if I explain that
to him and we talk through it okay cool
we made a hard decision we had to suck
it up but and the team is going to work
harder like when they're happy yeah and
they have ownership they buy in so there
you go don't make emotional decisions uh
but that's what's cool sorry to
interrupt but that's what's cool about
is when you drive ownership you're
actually it calculated into this into
this step of the emotions not just your
emotions but the emotions of your people
and I'm building up the emotions in a
positive manner of my people when I give
them ownership people like to have
ownership they like to have control and
now that they are in a good emotional
place it's a better work environment
which affects all these other things in
a positive manner so they do a better
job yes period in the story
perform all right check uh fast forward
a little bit
perspective in the SEAL Teams when
performing reconnaissance of a Target
building we observe the target from as
many possible angles as we can we do
this so that we can better understand
all aspects of the target if we only
observed the north side of a building we
wouldn't comprehend what was on the
south side where there might be an enemy
fighting position if we only observed
the west side of a Target building we
wouldn't understand the east side so we
Endeavor to observe the target from the
north south east and west we want to
understand every different perspective
and its possibilities similarly when
making business decisions we have to
understand the problem we are faced with
from as many angles as possible we do
this by collecting inputs from the
people involved with the
problem so listening to other people
finding out what's going on
understanding their perspective it's
everything we just talked about if I see
that my team is angry what's their
perspective why are they mad about this
they should be happy like we got a new
client there's more work to do
everyone's going to make more money oh
they're mad because they haven't had a
break in N9 weeks right you can and it
still doesn't cash out with as much
money as they're making compared to how
hard they're going to have to
work so understanding other people's
perspectives absolutely
critical and I say this to ensure you
see the fullest possible picture when
making a decision ask yourself
what can I do to see and understand more
what do my subordinates see what do my
peers see what does my boss see what
does my competition see have I asked
enough questions what am I not
seeing just asking yourself like when
you said earlier your perspectives
flawed of course your perspective is
flawed you only have your
perspective we have to ask questions and
try and understand other people's
perspectives so we can make better
decisions
next
one Mission tactical and strategic the
term Mission creep originated in the
military but is morphed into civilian
vernacular it refers to situations where
organizations expand the scope of their
goals beyond their originally intended
Mission as the mission objectives expand
over time there is less and less focus
on the original intent of the mission
often causing a failure to achieve the
original Mission so when making a
leadership decision it is critical to
assess the original Mission objective
and ensure that the decision supports
the original intent and that it will not
squander resources required to achieve
the actual
Mission so again if you're making a
decision you've got to think about that
decision is this helping us get to our
long-term strategic goal is it what
we're supposed to be focused on right
now and this is something that throws
off all kinds of
people it wrecks companies sometimes
yeah it wrecks families
sometimes cuz we're thinking short term
or we're doing things that we shouldn't
be
doing so you've got to always ask
yourself is this our mission this is
another one we were talking earlier
about like uh hey we're going to build
this thing and it's going to take all
these resources and I'm like hey I got
an idea why we just not build that you
know or like hey instead of like trying
to hammer on this door for the next 30
minutes why don't we just walk through
the window or you know go through the
window in 30 seconds this is another one
like people will start talking about
something and I'll be like hey is this
even our
mission is this even our mission to do
this like is this what we want to do do
we want to focus on this right now
because we we obviously we can do it but
is this what we are doing is this what
our mission is cuz if it's not our
mission why are we doing
it and often times like well we just
kind of you get a little Target fixation
right there's some Niche product to make
there's some Niche need in the market
and you're like oh I think we could do
that and you probably could but is it
your
mission so thinking about that
intentionally thinking like okay is this
actually my mission I have a
construction company that builds you
know uh I have a roofing company cool
and all of a sudden you get someone
that's like hey when you get done with
our roof can you do our
gutters and you can yeah and you can say
you know what we can do that
and maybe that's an expansion that you
make but maybe you run the numbers and
maybe you say look gutters is kind of a
uh a little bit more niche market we
live in Arizona there's not a lot of
rain here gutters last a long
time you know what why don't we
subcontract out this gutter system right
and instead of now investing in a bunch
of equipment and research and people and
training to get the guys up to speed
where they can do
no it was a
waste so let's not do that let's not
allow Mission creep
in Brad cner was really good at
reminding guys that trade at that in
what way he would just say hey is this
what we need to be focused on like it
was just a very simple and uh I mean
he's out he's retired now but I'll use
his nickname wink um he he would
literally do the same thing hey is this
what we need to be focusing on right now
and guys would be like okay I remember
they set up a breaching scenario one
time and guys were just having the hard
like they were so focused on like this
section of the door getting through the
problem dude 18 Ines away like a little
bit over so at an angle up on the wall
was the key on a little thumb tack MH
the key that unlocked the door it was
right there and I remember they they put
together that scenario and I was just
like man this is awesome and guys were
like just fighting on trying to get get
the door unlocked and they can't get it
they're trying to kick it and they're
trying to do all this stuff and they're
getting ready to call up the breacher
but they had the breachers focused on
some other bigger problem so they
couldn't get those resources over and
right there and I remember wink and d
and and Brad just pointing at the key in
these guys are like it was just a good
reminder from hey detach step back and
and just look at the big picture and it
was just I just remember Brad when you
know run and trading just just reminding
like hey is this what we need to be
focused on hey what are we working on
right now guys and it's just and that's
what good leaders do it's it's okay to
say that to your people hey guys what is
this what we need to be focused on is
this what we need to be focused like
what are we supposed to be working on
right
now you're not being direct you're not
saying hey this is what you need to be
focused on it's it's that indirect
approach again hey guys what do we need
to be focused on right now and you're
like well clearly not this right now yep
I always know like if you and ler asking
me questions I'm probably not doing the
right thing or you don't know why I'm
working on something which means I have
failed to communicate to you guys what
why we're working on something I know
it's one of those you're asking
questions cuz you don't have information
or you yeah you don't understand it you
truly don't understand like cuz in your
mind it's like one you don't have enough
information or two you don't you don't
understand why would I be doing this and
so instead of going direct and saying
hey that's stupid why would you be doing
that you're like hey what what does JP
know that I don't know and so you're
asking me a question so anytime you guys
or anybody Jamie Dave any any anybody in
my life has asked me questions I'm like
oh they they don't have enough
information we don't have alignment we
are not aligned and that's my fault yeah
the and another thing talking about like
that key on the
Thumbtack that will get nine out of 10
people that they won't see that thing
this is this is one of those situations
where being you in in a if you're in a
seal platoon you can literally afford to
be DET you if you you can be afford to
be detached the entire time because no
one else is like like bunch of sled do
they see that freaking door with a bunch
of freaking with a lock on it and
there's noise behind the door they know
something going on they want to get in
there nine out of 10 guys are going to
just they're G to how do we get through
this door how do we breach this thing
get the sledgehammer up what kind of
charge am I going to put on this thing
you can afford to be the guy that's just
like constantly at highport looking
around cuzz no one else is going to see
that key yeah and and it's so weird to
be in that situation you'll see you'll
see so much that other guys aren't going
to see so it's the same thing in your
company chances are in your company when
you've got some product that everyone's
all a sudden like hey you think we could
make this you think we could well do we
have the right tools for this yeah we
have the right tools hey where do we
need to order from what what how is it
built how long will it take and
everyone's going to focus on that
problem and they're going to start
working on it and they're going to start
moving down that path and the next thing
you know you've created a product with a
bunch of expenses and a bunch of of time
and a bunch of effort that seven people
in the world need and it's freaking
worthless and if you would have just
took a step back in like 5 minutes into
this pulled a brad caver and be like hey
is this what we should be focused on
right now and everyone look at each
other and as soon as people look at each
other they're like oh yeah you're right
yeah as soon as they as soon as Brad
points up to the key and you're like oh
I'm an idiot you don't think like that's
trickery no you think like I'm an idiot
yeah I'm an
idiot yeah so
Jack rest in peace um
y next section
here
relationships this is the last thing I
consider when making a decision but it
is the most heavily weighted of all the
items in this leadership Loop checklist
I know this might seem strange after all
the stereotypical priorities of a leader
are things like accomplishing the
mission managing resources and ensuring
timely execution but for me building and
maintaining relationships is the most
important thing a leader does because
relationships are the force that holds
the team together the stronger the
relationships the stronger the team the
stronger the team the better the results
the team achieves because of that it is
important to remember that every
decision a leader makes either builds or
denigrates relationships I want every
interaction I have with anyone on my
team up down or across the chain of
command to build our relationship this
is not to say I'm always able to do that
but I absolutely always
try so this is one of those things that
I think is counterintuitive for people
that when you're in a leadership
position and you're making a decision
you can should and must way how this is
going to impact the relationships that
you have with the people in the team and
it's sort of like the person that we
just talked about that might be like I
don't care what you know I don't care if
you're mad or not this is what we're
doing there's some people that are like
hell yeah bro that's what a leader does
you know it's like a leader makes those
hard decisions right they we hear that
all the time like no a Leader's not
going to freaking just Cow Town cuz
someone's frustrated it's like okay okay
I get you here are there times where
you're going to make decisions as a
leader that are going to make that's
going to make the team mad yep are there
times where that relationship's going to
get sacrificed a little bit yep there
are there are I have made decisions in
my life that I know negatively impacted
my relationship with somebody and I had
to work through to build it back up I've
been through that countless times we all
have but to not recognize that and not
be intentional about saying hold on a
second there's six in one half dozen the
other but if I choose six ekko's going
to be frustrated or JP's going to be
angry or our relationship is going to be
negatively impacted why don't I just go
with a dozen
or half dozen why don't I just do that
people make decisions all the time
without considering how it's going to
impact
relationships and this is the biggest
mistake you can
make so what is a relationship
again in the book I talk about it trust
listen respect influence and Care what's
interesting about to build these fast
forward a little bit to build
relationships with these attributes one
must take a L counterintuitive approach
and proactively give first if you want
someone to trust you you must first put
some trust in them if to get someone to
listen to you you have to listen to them
the more you talk the less people listen
respect must be given to be received
trying to demand respect does not work
in fact it backfires by the way you
better freaking respect
me to become influential over someone
the first step is allowing that
individual to influence you you and
obviously if you want someone to care
about you you must first dis display how
you care about them and then I go on to
talk about your
ego stifle can stifle these efforts it's
so interesting
right if I don't want to I don't want to
put any trust in in JP well why not well
because I don't think he can do it as
good as me that's ego uh J she JP should
be listening to me since I've been doing
this longer cuz I have more experience
because I've been in this position he
should be listening to me that's ego by
the
way JP better treat me with respect I've
earned it okay that's your ego your ego
thinks it's earned all kinds of
that it hasn't
earned uh why should I be influenced by
JP he should be influenced by me that's
ego and obviously I'm supposed to put
JP's needs above my own which is a weird
thing to think about right think about
that there's a whole like road we could
go down of what's that saying uh got to
look out for number one right number you
know what I'm saying who's number one
you got hey man look I got to look out
for number one so that's my ego so when
I say look I you know JP's G to kind of
get screwed on this deal but you know I
got to take care of
me okay okay how's that going to work
out how's that relationship looking
how's that trust going like it's just a
disaster and it's all ego well that's
where that's where people will uh twist
what you said earlier because they hear
from other people like pay yourself
first and that's the mistake that people
will make is like well I got to make
sure hey I got to get mine y I got to
get mine and they they take that the
wrong way and it's they don't understand
the the major leadership withdrawals
that they're making and just how bad
that actually is ruining relationships
cuz people see that and they know they
know exactly what you're doing
as you've said hundreds of thousands of
times your intent has a smell and if it
stinks none of us like it no it's like
that sweaty ghee sitting in the back of
your car in the summer Texas summer
yeah yeah there's uh probably nothing
worse than a ghee that like got left
somewhere burn it and just order a new
from us that's what we got to do
um I go on to say this to ensure you are
protecting and building relationships
instead of diminishing them ask yourself
how will this decision impact my
relationships again I say this is the
most heavily weighted thing which I
think throws people off right because as
a leader it's like no I'm going to get
the job done right we're going to save
we're going to get the resources we
that's everyone thinks it's like no
actually make your priority let's make
sure we're building that relationship
because if we're not building
relationship what do we
have what do we have we have a shitty
team
team if the impact is negative are there
any options that will more positively
impact
relationships if the impact is negative
is it worth the return on investment
like I said I've made decisions that
have hurt relationships that I've had
with people where I've been like look
dude Eko I know that like the the video
look the video that you made it's a
really good video and I appreciate it
but we're going to use car's video like
there's sometimes where I've got to like
that's going to hurt our relationship
like ekko's mad you know like our
relationship just took a step back but
like let's face it his video wasn't as
good as car's in this whatever situation
and that's going to hurt our
relationship but for the
business that's what we got to do and
that's the way it is so I've had to make
decisions I've had to make a lot of
decisions like that but I only do it
let's the ROI cuz you know what if Ekko
made a video that was pretty good and
Carrie made one that was better but I
knew that Ekko was like super emotional
and attached to this video that he made
and like the difference wasn't that big
of AAL I be like yeah Eko man your video
is good let's launch that thing and
there's some people right now that are
like yeah but if your Roi would have
been better it's like okay but we have
to think strategically because if my Roi
was a little bit better with car's video
than it was with ekko's and so we we we
did a little bit better we did 4% better
but now now
Ekko he's he's a little bit pissed off
how much effort is he put in his next
video it's getting worse right matter of
fact he probably he might not even make
you you know Echo this is after Eko made
10 videos and they were all better than
car's and car's videos like we're just
like hey that's good we'll throw it on
the back burner finally Carrie comes out
with the big
win and but we so we we use his video
and I'm like Eko sorry dude this is not
this not the time eo's frustrated man
mhm that relationship just got hurt what
are we doing is it worth it it long term
is it worth it so is it sometimes worth
it yes sometimes it's worth it sometimes
you have to make those
decisions most of the time it's like I'm
going to protect the relationship that's
my that's like I said it's the heaviest
weighted thing I
have and I'll tell you like this is the
way you have to operate if you're not
operating like this look you look you're
going to be successful for a while you
can leave a scorched Earth policy and
Everywhere You Go everyone hates you and
you have no true friends and it's just a
nightmare and a disaster and and by the
way where that ends up you make some
money along the way or you'll build your
business or you'll get promoted or
whatever it is you're looking for you'll
get it short term and then you look up
in three four five years and it's just
scorched Earth and there's nothing else
to burn right yeah there's nothing else
to burn well you'll always be chasing
that fulfillment that you can't actually
achieve because when you do what you're
talking about there's
fulfillment when you do what when you
all these things you're talking about
yeah everything in this Loop when you do
those things when you're an actual
leader and again you don't a title
doesn't make you a leader doing these
things is what makes you a leader you
know building trust you know listening
to your people showing them respect like
influenc on them that's what that's what
makes you a leader is your ability to
build the relationships with people
around you instill belief into them
belief in the mission and and actually
go Inspire them to take action that's
what makes you a leader and you know
when you do all these principles that
you're talking about that brings you
fulfillment when you violate all these
things you're going to be chasing
fulfillment until the day that you die
and it doesn't matter how much money you
make it doesn't all these things will
not matter but you can also get all of
these other things that some people like
that matters to them while also being a
good leader and and what we've seen is
the people that have good intentions
that are taking care of their people and
they're they're out there serving people
they tend to get what they need and want
in life and like that's the true thing
is like that happiness comes from peace
not from all the like the things that
people are chasing like that the
happiness comes from peace of being a
good leader and serving and and taking
care of people yeah yeah and if you
prioritize your relationships and part
of inherent in relationships is caring
about other people if that's what your
focus is I'm going promise you I
guarantee you I guarantee you you will
end up better in the long term period
end of story yep when you sacrifice
relationships when you don't listen to
people when you hurt when you don't care
about people when you do those things in
your life I I'm going to tell you like I
said you're going to get some short-term
wins sure you know I freaking came out
better with the business deal and you
know JP was building this thing for me
and I kind of like pushed back on what
he wanted to charge and he came in and
finally he got it done and I didn't pay
him what he really wanted
okay dude I won right I you built my
deck for me you built the deck on on my
house and you wanted five grand and I
got you to do it for 4,200 I won right
you know what I'm saying I won short
term right I saved 800
bucks you know what happens what happens
well you know my roof's leaking one day
and I need some help and I called JP
what does he say sorry man I'm busy or
that you know this is the way life works
you know I sacrific the
relationship for
me right I sacrifice the I make a
decision that's good for me not good for
you yeah and that's not going to work
out good now you could also be saying
you know jono I'll do it but I can only
do your deck for you know
$6,000 and I go man I mean we ran the
numbers and I looked at the labor and
the cost of the stuff it's like five
grand is really fair and you're like I
can only do it for six grand
sorry okay so I pay you six grand you
know and yet you and I both know that's
not fair we don't have the same
relationship that we did an hour ago
before we shook hands on this
deal so now who's building my you know
my next house in three years when I've
become wealthy and I'm like actually I
need a whole house built yeah guess
who's not getting the job JP's not try
to get that extra little bit of
something out of me
MH so if you make decisions and you
consider relationships and you wait that
heavily again dude are there times yes
there's absolutely times I get it all
you people that are right now like
that's not good leadership sometimes you
got to just freaking close the door
you're on this you're on the ship and
the ship gets hit with a torpedo and
there's guys in the engine room and you
seal that freaking door and those guys
are going to die
now that's a decision that gets
made and you do that to save the ship I
get it and some of the guys on the ship
are going to be filled with hatred
yeah you made that decision there are
times when you have to put those things
aside we get it we understand
that but I'm telling you when you're
running this decision Loop in normal
life prioritize these
relationships that's the way it
works there was
a few times where you'd be in this
situation um obviously on a very small
scale but what I did notice that Joo
would do JP and you'll probably vouch
for this as well anytime where like
there's a decision that maybe I wouldn't
have necessarily agreed with or be like
right on board with you'd always explain
the bigger picture M kind of like um
like okay you know hey look this is what
we're doing this is what we're doing hey
follow me this is why and because of
this and the more you explain kind of
the big picture the more acceptable it
starts to become and it's like okay and
just like I said yeah yeah they won't
you said they might not like you for it
but I would say in my experience it's
not that they don't I wouldn't like you
or I'd like you less it would be that I
wouldn't like it necessarily it's good
keep so the relationship is essentially
maintained but even though I'm doing
something that I really don't want to do
but I know why I'm doing it so it's kind
of like okay I get it's kind of like
telling your kids to clean the room
right hey we're going to go to uh
Disneyland today but before you go you
got to clean your room they'll be like
what like oh my gosh I was excited for
day no no clean the room if they
understand hey you got to clean your
room clean room's good all this stuff
and they understand they're like okay
they don't like cleaning their room all
of a sudden but at least they'll suck it
up they'll do it get it done do it'll be
done and then boom Disneyland time you
see what I'm saying yeah yeah it's
that's why communication is the number
one skill set of a good leader like you
have to have the ability to communicate
and if like you were saying like when
you do those you explain the why and you
can clearly articulate that to your
people they may not like like what has
to be done but they understand it and
then they can actually get on board and
then if you can drive ownership down to
them in regards to what we're doing and
why we're doing it then there's going to
be less push back more buying and a
great example of that is like hey here's
what we got to do here's why we got to
do it how do you guys want to get it
done right I mean that's something that
I use Almost 100% of the time like hey
look I know there's a lot of debate
about us doing this thing here's why we
got to do this thing let me know how you
guys want to do
but we got to get it done like that's
just that's just good leadership right
there and and the point is there that
the the relationship part of it gets
maintained even though they're doing
stuff they don't want to do you told
them to do stuff they don't want to do
they got to suck it up like even with
like kids for example like you know
dessert right you're the dad who says no
to desserts man they're not going to
like you you know yeah you think so you
think oh these kids are not going to
like me I'm going to say no to their
dessert on the weekend oh my gosh you
know but if you explain to him here's
one a little hack you guys can borrow I
mean I'm sure a little bit more advanced
than me but for anyone listening who
might want to use this one this works be
like hey um I don't know what's
unhealthy freaking Donuts sugar cookies
donuts for sure but Donuts aren't for
dessert yeah people have them for
breakfast cupcakes Okay cupcakes good
one so cupcakes um you know for oh what
no cupcake and be like why oh why you
not going to let us have cupcakes that's
what they're focused on right you didn't
let me have this pleasure cupcakes be
like hey we hey we know how bad cupcakes
are you know nobody's perfect I get it
but we know how bad cupcakes are would I
be a good dad if I just willingly gave
you these unhealthy cupcakes would that
make me a good dad it's very hard to
refute that for little kids little bit
older kids they might be more clever
they might think up some stuff but
little kids it works hey I've here's a
mistake I made with my kids it's just
like good one to remember too it's a
little hint is I've done the like I'm
taking ownership yeah and been like
listen obviously I haven't done a good
job explaining to you why this is
important or something like that and
like my my oldest daughter when she was
younger she'd be like I'm not a bad
person like as if I'd be like I'd be
like you know hey obviously I haven't
done a good job explaining the
importance of whatever and she'd be like
Dad I'm not like a bad person like you
don't have to say that as if you have
failed as a father cuz that's the way I
would make it sound that makes sense to
me completely okay I I get it didn't you
get scolded for like the type two
diabetes speech or something you give to
your kids didn't I get scolded yeah like
by your wife probably or uh but I I'll
tell you I would give the type two
diabetes speech to my kids like you know
oh you want a cupcake cool you want type
two diabetes too like I must have said
that a lot when they were growing up so
okay so here and as funny as that is
like the serious part of that is I mean
obviously that's partially joking the
way you always do it or whatever you
might go a little bit too hard for some
people I get it but nonetheless I
recognize it so well earlier on this
podcast we were talking about oh you
didn't clean your room cool you don't
eat or whatever you don't help clean it
up you don't eat we're going to get some
on that one I guarantee you people
are going to be like you're this sick
person yeah I mean obviously there's
more to it you know like some kids
they're kind of picky eaters and they'll
just starve them themselves they'll be
like whatever starve myself meanwhile
they're losing weight and and look there
it's
Nuance this is that's not what we're
talking about we're not talking about a
kid losing weight cuz they didn't clean
up the dishes at lunch and now they're
not getting dinner we're going into a
whole different realm right now no no no
the the point of making is there's more
to it than just like okay you don't need
you know there process okay so the so
you going no but just for the record
none of my kids have ever lost weight
because I freaking uh guilt trip though
yes I understand fully but and that's
part of the point like different
families are different different kids
are different than your kids you know
specifically whatever environment yeah
you know there's going to be adjustments
and by the way there's all there are you
know people out there that they need to
do the opposite they need to eat right
they have like e eating disorders and
stuff like that which are really
horrific so exactly right we have to be
careful around this subject yeah so but
the point is as far as you you know
halfway joke and you go hard you know
all this stuff or whatever and you say
oh yeah you want type two diabetes you
know every time shoot freck man we just
wanted a little bit of that frozen
yogurt you know to right now whatever
and so bra you don't have to go that
hard so if you go too hard for your kids
I could see I'm not saying it will but I
could see how that could kind of jam up
the relationship a little bit could jam
up the relationship could get Rebellion
we're just sugar addicts now yeah
exactly right and that's what I'm saying
and really when we focusing because this
what you're talking about it's the
relationship right that you're trying to
maintain that's why I came up with this
clever one be like would I be a good dad
you know like cuz I'm trying to be the
best dad isn't that what you want this
it's hard I mean you get a smart like
kid cool but the kid's not going to be
like no I don't want you to be a good
dad so it's like they have no rebuttal
you know so you say would I be a good
dad if I just fed you this terrible
unhealthy stuff it's just really hard to
refute you know and the m and the
relationship gets maintained check this
out here's a hole you want to open up a
can right now yes sir here's do no doubt
about check this out hey you're supposed
to be their their dad or their mom not
their friend right this is another one
of those things I and look I get the
concept right I get the concept because
people say the same thing about
leadership too like hey you're not
you're you're supposed to be their
leader not their friend you're supposed
to be their platoon Chief not their
friend you're supposed to be platoon
Commander not their friend you're
supposed to be their CEO not their
friend you're supposed to be their
department head not their friend this is
a very common and there's a common theme
of like you're supposed to be their mom
not their friend or their dad not their
friend
yeah and I get it I get what they're
trying to say right what they're trying
to say is like hey I'm not trying to
make you know JP my buddy by being like
hey buddy like I'm your boss but you
know can I blah blah blah can let's you
you can leave work early like like oh it
doesn't oh you're my son hey JP son uh
oh you want your buddies to come over
and have beer cool I'll have some beers
with you guys that that attitude right
that when people say don't be their
friend that's what they're talking about
yeah like oh you you guys want to you
know you guys want to go see whatever
I'll take guys are smoking pot it's no
big deal you know I'm like cool with
that like that's what they're talking
about right but to think that you
wouldn't want to have a relationship
with your kids that isn't
like a being a their friend is an aspect
of it to me is crazy I'm friends with
all my kids like my kids are my friends
like 100%
And I I just want to warn people and but
but by the way everyone that works for
me you know everyone that's my employee
which I never say that but everyone that
works in the companies that I
own they're like my friends there's not
like well you know you got to remember
I'm the boss here never said have I ever
said anything like that before like
that's a crazy thing no and for me to so
so I would just keep that in mind and
again I know that there's people right
now that are like I'm going to be a you
know I'm meant to be the dad not the
friend it's like I'm telling you you can
be both and I would encourage you to be
both I would tell you that there's
things that your daughter or son may not
tell their father mhm but they'll tell
their friend 100% And so when your kid
might be going through some kind of
trouble and you know whether they're
getting picked on whether they're having
a hard time with something whether
they're like breaking up with their
boyfriend or girlfriend whatever those
things are you're not if you're not
their friend and you're just their dad
you might not hear about it so I'm
saying there is a element of
friendship as a leader
and it's a positive thing it's not a
negative thing and it's part of
relationships right the components that
make up a relationship in a business
relationship are the same components
that make up a relationship in a friend
relationship and the same things that
make up a relationship in a father
mother daughter spouse relationship
trust listen respect influence and care
that's what a relationship is don't you
want to have that with your kids don't
you want your kids to trust you don't
you want your kids to listen to you yep
you do guess what you better listen to
your kids then but my kid's only nine he
doesn't know anything okay don't listen
to him and see how that works out when
your 9-year-old kid has an issue about
something tell him shut up you don't
know what you're talking about you're
too young that doesn't matter when your
kid gets called a plate face in school
and comes home is a little bit te DED
and you say what's wrong and you say I
got made fun of and you go hey shut up
sticks and stones break your bones names
can never hurt you don't worry about it
and that's your
reaction I'm telling you you you're not
listening to them and therefore guess
what they're not going to listen to you
yeah so this relationship thing is
universal and the better relationships
you have with people the better things
are going to be in your life period end
of
story and it also includes people that
you may not
necessarily
like so you might work for someone that
you don't necessarily
like I work for JP JP's arrogant he goes
flies off the handle he yells at me and
the rest of our
employees the rest of my
peers so what do I try and do well I
don't like him so I'm not going to build
a relationship to with him okay so then
where does that get us in life do things
get better for me or worse for me do I
have more influence over him or less
influence can I get him to stop yelling
at me when all I do is not listen to him
and disrespect him nope yelling is going
to get louder and worse if I treat him
with respect maybe just maybe he'll
start to treat me with respect if I
listen to him he's yelling at me and I
get out my notebook and start taking
notes he's like what the hell are you
doing I just want to write down what
you're saying boss I want to make sure I
got this that's a that's an attitude
changer does this make me an ass kisser
nope doesn't means that I want to win
means I want to improve my situation for
me and for my team that's what it means
so these relationship things even when
it's someone that you might not like I
have worked with a lot of people in my
life that I didn't
like I've worked with a lot of people in
my life that I didn't like Jamie and
Dave are always wondering if it's
them they joke about that they're like
is it me is it me no it could be but
I'll never tell
them you might you work with people that
you don't like what good is it if they
know know that what good is it if you're
not trying to build a relationship the
best thing to do is build that
relationship and move things forward you
have no influence over people that you
don't have a relationship with they
don't listen to a word that you say so
build relationships this is a winning
this is a way to win or you can go
through life like I don't do that and
you know who says I don't do that my ego
says I don't do that my ego says JP
yelled at me I'm not going to listen to
a damn thing he says that's my ego
instead of being like Oh JP yelled at me
I wonder what kind of bosses he worked
for that he thinks that's a good
move I wonder what kind of childhood he
had where he loses his temper all the
time I wonder what's going on in his
house with his wife and kids where he
seems real short with the rest of the
team
H I wonder if everything's perfect in
JP's life where he's coming into to work
late he's mad he's yelling at people I
wonder if he's just got a great thing
going on right now like you think
through these things and it's really
easy to say you know what maybe I can be
a little a little bit better of a human
being
here so prioritize those
relationships last thing on this
list it's repeat once I have run through
this checklist loop I will make a
decision and then run through the
checklist check checklist loop again and
again as a leader I must continually
assess these components over and over
again and consider the feedback I
receive with each decision and how the
decisions affect the situation to do
this I must do two things
[Music]
detach and keep an open
mind Detachment is a superpower as the
failure or inability to detach causes a
failure to see clearly don't get too
absorbed in any one aspect of the
decision take a step back and breathe to
assess the components of your decision
from a broad and unemotional vantage
point and to integrate your observations
into your decision-making process you
have to keep an open mind keeping an
open mind mind is always a challenge
outside ideas feel threatening to our
beliefs don't be intransigent or let
those feeling close your mind invite
those thoughts and recognize that
challenges test your ideas and make them
better open mind and
attachment
to
very difficult things for human beings
it's very difficult to keep an open mind
and it's very difficult to
detach and in order for this leadership
Loop in order to get the feedback you
have to
detach and you have to keep an open
mind new ideas we don't like them
challenging ideas we don't like them
differences of opinion we don't like
them we literally surround ourselves
with people that have the same opinions
as
us go on to social media who are you
following I'm fing a bunch of people
that are the same as me yep that's what
we're doing what news do I watch I watch
the news that has the same opinion as
me it's like that's what we do because
our our mind wants to be closed it wants
to just not hear anyone else's
opinion because we think we're
right so there you have it that's a a
little section of this new addition that
I added to leadership strategy and
tactics Field Manual uh pragmatic it's a
pragmatic book uh and that's how the
book's
designed and you know you were saying
this
earlier JP talking about referring to
books and sometimes we got to go back to
the
book sometimes we got to go back to the
book
the harshest example I have of that is
the book discipline equals freedom field
manual was coming out and it was coming
out like October 15th
2017 and I had the book it showed up at
my house I had boxes of the book and it
was like you know was signing them or
doing whatever and Stoner
died
um and so it's like September 30th and
so I had a whole bunch of you know press
and all this like trip to the east coast
and all this stuff were that I was doing
for for promotion of discipline equals
freedom field manual
and so whatever that's all happening or
supposed to happen and uh you know
Stoner dies and kind of maybe a day goes
by so sort of like all these initial
kind of like calls you know we're all
you know we're all talking to each other
we're figuring out what's going on we're
starting to plan stuff and and like that
time had gone by that first like day had
had gone by of where you're kind of in
the reaction mode of we have
administrative stuff that we've got to
do and then it was so now like that was
gone and it was the first like time
where I I was left alone with my
thoughts and I remember I was in my room
I don't know where my wife and kids were
gone or whatever and I'm just in my room
by myself and I'm laying on my bed at in
the afternoon which I don't Norm de I'm
laying in my bed in the afternoon and I
started to just
freaking go down the the the spiral of
anger
and resentment
and just
unproductive terrible uh
darkness
and I
literally felt
the abyss like opening up like dude I'm
this
is it just it's just all this is all
it's all dark it's all horrible and
I felt that I kind of like f felt the
draw of
that and I like stopped myself and I I
actually sat up and I had this big box
of discipline equal freedom field manual
and there's a whole section in there
about death and I had to I I had to I
had
to open that up and read that section of
myself and get a freaking grip on
reality
and that's the that's the way life is
you are going to need help you're going
to need
reminders you're going to
need
support and for me to be able to refer
back to a book
look you know for that terrible Moment
In My
Life um that's kind of like what the
that's kind of what these books are
for
and the the the leadership strategy and
tactics Field Manual obviously a much
more positive book because it's about
positive things it's about leadership
it's about moving
forward but over time you can develop
these
instincts and over time you can learn to
deal
with tough situations
but you might get into a scenario where
you need some help you need some support
and you know for from a leadership
perspective that's what that book
leadership strategy and tactics is about
you might get really good at that
leadership
Loop when I'm having trouble making a
decision I I'll Whip that thing open and
be like hold on a second let me think
through these
steps if you think through those steps
you get to the end you're going to have
a pretty good idea of what to do
yeah
so leadership strategy and tactics Field
Manual sometimes you got to refer you
know I mean we referred to the Bible
today a book many many people refer to
right there's you you can be rooted in
things we need reminders you have a
tattoo on your wrist to remind you of
things you have a hat in your closet it
from Marco's Pizza to remind you of
things we need to put those things in
our
lives and when we
stray that's that's what happens right
we
stray we stray from what we know we
should be doing we stray from
remembering where we came from we stray
from our
humility we stray from leadership
principles that we've talked about or
lived or read about over and over
again we stray from the understanding of
life and death we stray from these
things and we have to bring ourselves
back to
them and it's it's not easy but this is
another part where I think feeling that
disturbance in the
force well what I talked about if you
have some uh for me if I have some sort
of emotional disturbance in the force I
immediately know okay this is a this is
my
ego if I'm having trouble making a
decision if it's not clear to
me okay guess what maybe I need to get
out the field manual and go through this
leadership decision making
Loop that that just bring me
back so you've got to set these things
up but most important if you don't Rec
if you don't don't
detach you won't be able to
see what's happening and where you're
straying or that you are straying in the
first place you know when I was sitting
there thinking about Stoner I was
straying from what I know is the right
thing to do in that
situation and
luckily I was detached enough to go hold
on a second you're not going to a good
place right now yeah this is not good
you you're straying from what you know
is good you're straying from the light
and you're moving towards the dark and
this is not
good if you're not detached and when
people not aren't detached when we watch
people go down spiral into destruction
that could be from a leadership
perspective that could be from a
personal perspective that could be from
a family perspective most of the time
they haven't had the ability to detach
and take a look at themselves and go
what am I doing right now you know they
always put in a movie scene like a guy
looking at himself in the mirror or a
woman look at him themselves in the
mirror
right it's like that's where they see oh
God what am I doing right now what am I
becoming or that catch the
reflection that that we have to do that
we have to look at ourselves and examine
ourselves and you you have to detach to
be able to do that when when you're not
detached you're just caught in the
moment you're doing you're wasting time
you're doing evil things
right you read that passage it's like
that's disturbance in the force we're
doing things that we are hiding we're
doing things in the dark yeah and a lot
of times you you you're lying to
yourself you're ignoring the fact that
you're wasting time you're ignoring the
fact that you you are doing something
you shouldn't be
doing you're doing something you
shouldn't be doing and you're lying to
yourself and you don't think anyone can
see
you but it's having an impact
and the number one person that needs to
see what's happening is you and if you
cover your eyes to it you're not going
to see
it so keep those things in
mind Don't Stray From the
Path and be aware that's I'm telling you
that's the thing is people they don't
make a right turn off the path they
don't they're not like walking down the
path and they take a right turn and then
they're off that's not what happens they
take like a three degree turn and they
can't really tell and they're kind of
like well you know it's like I I'm still
kind of on it and then they travel more
distance and they're not looking around
they're not paying attention to next
thing you know they're they're totally
off the path and their life is going in
the wrong
direction so find some ways to ground
yourself find some things to some
references to refer
to write things down hang things up give
yourself reminders refer back what did
you say you read a Psalm or a proverb a
day yeah that's a a methodology
right here's a book with Timeless
information in it yeah and instruction
and guidance open it up read it it takes
you 38
seconds okay we just reminded ourselves
where we're supposed to be
going do
that do those things
to keep yourself on the
path in all aspects of your
life
um probably good on the books uh
leadership strategy and
tactics feel me I'll get it but brand
new edition's out it's got a cooler
cover too by the way Echo Charles
blacked yeah yeah I like it the original
Ed dish was olive drab OD Green you know
and then this one we went we went uh
Black Ops tactical tactical it's more
it's you know you know black is not
actually a good tactical color in most
cases actually you know where I got the
year watch Robocop not the old school
one the newer one Michel Keon he was
like when they're formulating the
RoboCop suit suit which is classically
silver or stainless steel
whatever Michael Keaton was like um oh
uh I I mean we need to change it from
the silver is there anything a little
bit more tactical mhm B black that's
where I got it from yeah they went black
but it black stands out a lot I got you
understand yeah I think this to us what
do you call them normies people not in
the game or whatever like we just we
just feel like oh it's at night black
you know can't see you it's more
tactical I'm saying I don't know anyway
please continue yeah but this one is
black I can say tactical maybe it's not
the best tactical color but it's the
coolest color let's face it that looks
cool and it's got the night vision green
on it too
which actually looks really cool I like
that a lot so that's the Expanded
Edition I always refer people to page
157 158 in leadership strategy and
tactics Field Manual it's like the 12
list of 12 things to do as leader what's
going on what are you doing no no no
these two are different right now well
okay so the one that you have in your
left hand is a fake copy okay got it was
it was like a like a proof copy of what
the cover was going to look like but you
can see the the fake one is glossy the
real one is a little bit more matte
black yeah that's to so that's cool Pro
there you go um JP you got other stuff
going on right now obviously you got all
your stuff at Eon front going on yep uh
running the training you're the chief
chief training officer there which put
you like you already talked about the
FTX you got the battlefield events you
got the council not a training facility
Le and I have been talking about that
recently and you know driving that you
know Cody Danny Justin I know Justin's
working right now on building out like
the specs for kind of what we want
trying to get an idea you know working
with Mike and our you know our
accounting department of okay hey what
is this training department going to
look like or like a training location
where people can come and not just only
have access to our our our field
training exercise but having a nice
awesome training facility with
classrooms and being able to host and
facilitate all aspects of the training
that we do at Echelon FR I mean I guess
the only thing that we couldn't
replicate would be a battlefield review
because well yeah we're not you got be
on the battle you got to be on the
battlefield but these days with some of
the uh technology that's out there being
able to give really good briefs and
Vantage points and 360 degree like the
camera that you have uh Echo Charles we
could walk someone around an entire
Battlefield no problem actually yeah and
it'd be virtual but dude it'd be so we
got all kinds of stuff we're working
there and then so so you got you
mentioned it earlier the JP denell
podcast yeah um yeah started it actually
came out today today uh it's really um
um you know had it to where every Friday
it's going to launch we're on iTunes
Spotify YouTube yeah um yeah so if you
guys want to check it out you know and
you know if and if you like it like
subscribe to it you know leave us a
comment leave us a review um but yeah
the the purpose of me starting my own
podcast was what we've been talking
about today is just to provide value
it's just my perspective my Insight on
what we do at Echelon front you know to
share the stories from me growing up as
a kid the lessons that I learned from my
childhood um and also like the lessons
and stories and experiences I had from
being in the military specifically in
the sealed teams um you know when I got
out you know which I know we've covered
a lot of those stories over your podcast
uh but just to be able to elaborate and
just as we say pull the thread on
different stories that I have from my
life my perspective on on things and the
again just pulling it all back to what
we teach at Echelon front my my my
intention is to provide value to people
through the lessons that I've learned
the experiences that I get to have
because of what I get to do at Echelon
front to share people's stories pull the
Leadership Lessons out of people's
stories and tie it back into what we do
at Echelon front and uh just you know
also be able to share my faith and and
and just have a um have a different
platform form that it just hopefully
reaches more people to uh provide value
and bring them back to what we do at
Echelon front and um you know my buddy
Lucas is you know producing and hosting
and co-hosting it all with me it's I met
him because of the Jesus and Jiu-Jitsu
podcast that I do with my buddies
Stephen Isaac and Josh and it's a he
literally does everything and I remember
when I saw like the place that we record
it's in they converted a room in their
Church you know he's a pastor of a small
Baptist Church and in Denton Texas and
he created this when Co hit for hey it's
a way for us to get the message out to
different people and provide value to
people and um anyways the guy is awesome
um if you're watching on YouTube You'll
see he doesn't he does not look like
your typical Pastor he's got long- hair
beard he looks like a biker like you
know and and you know it's just it's
it's a cool opportunity and I'm I'm
thankful that I have someone like Lucas
to be able to do this because there's
zero 0% I'm going to be able to do all
the things that he does like I mean
could I learn how to do it yeah could
you learn how to do all the things Eko
does yeah but yeah
obviously but when we look at a priority
at time press record dude dude doesn't
do jazz and it just magically is
uploaded right messed up while you said
that so quickly like immediately but you
act like you're shocked and surprised
it's like I already knew the quickness
was pretty impressive it was impressive
yeah so I uh you know impressive quickly
I can insult you you're just ready just
oh good time so yeah I'm thankful for
that and then um you know other things
that we've talked about before uh little
cattco launched a few weeks ago Beef
Company I doing with Steven little and
that's been awesome and then um so where
do people go to get that little
cattle.co so little
cattle.co it's just our name as as a way
so little cattle Co is the name of the
comp so you can find us on Instagram but
if you want to order beef it's little
cattle.co and what's cool is like hey if
you just want to order two fillets and 5
pounds of ground beef you can do that
you want to order we uh we had somebody
recently reach out and you know they
wanted to order a bunch of ribe eyes for
for the team Co was that person named
Joo no not yet I have failed to get you
any of the beef yet we uh hey when you
get an order for 27 ribe eyes oh no
you'll know well is crazy I mean it's
only been a couple weeks and we we're
getting everything literally Stevens
right now getting all of our our
resupply I mean we sold out of Riis and
sirloins and tomahawks and brisket and I
mean it just was was pretty cool to see
how that happened uh we were able to
when we had the the one day ftxs last
week in in Texas um you know because we
wanted to provide you know as we do at
Eon front it's like hey take care of the
client provide really good value part of
it was like you know we realized on the
FTX is like we could increase the the
types of meals that we're providing to
our clients now the hard part is how do
we duplicate this because last week it
was good because Steven was out there uh
cooking hamburgers and Sirloin and
ground beef for everybody so everyone
had a half pound hamburger from little
catco uh sirloin even Leif was like he's
like man is that ribey and Stephen's
like no that's sirloin he's like there's
no way I mean as you know high quality
beef is different than what people are
used to and so uh it's you know it's
Texas Black Angus that that has no
hormones no antibiotics no steroids his
uncle uncle Rocky he's been doing this
for 30 years and that's how we have
access to all the steers and um just
good quality beef um I didn't know this
this is disgusting but you know
According to some of the experts out
there when it comes to ground beef that
you get from a grocery store or you know
some of the higher like the the bigger
names that Pro like in high volume that
you buy in bulk try not to say names um
you can have up to a thousand different
steers that you that ground beef is
being combined to make your ground beef
which that is increase the risk for
cross contamination and all this other
stuff um our ground beef comes from one
steer it's not even mixed with the four
steers that we Slaughter at a time it is
all it's from that that the chuck roast
and the fat like it's good quality high
quality ground beef big differ like a
big difference as you can tell um as I
know you know you're in the beef game
you know and you understand the value of
like that high quality beef and you know
Stephen and his uncle Rocky you know
handling all the um the business and you
know of the of the steers and the beef
and then Tyler and I um you know we
invested into the company and helping
with the business aspect of it and it's
cool that all of our families are
involved and the night before we you
know um started fulfilling orders like
all three of our families were up there
and we prayed over the warehouse and we
prayed over the orders and prayed over
our customers because we also understand
that this is an opportunity that we get
to to serve other people through our
products and um so I'm thankful for that
and man it's it's been really cool to
see how it's uh I mean God's definitely
blessed the business already which has
been great and then um the other thing
that we talked about is you know the the
on the path printing that Josh and I've
been doing and um you know both of us
you know we just it couldn't make it as
a it wasn't a top priority and that was
hard for us because our ego wanted it to
be hey done done done and but we really
both had to step back and like okay hey
what are the other priorities that we
have going on in our life and uh I also
had to listen to people that were like
hey man you got a lot of stuff going on
I'm like yeah I know and then I realiz
I'm like okay are they saying that
because they're envious or are they
saying that because they care about me
and I realized that the people were
saying it was because they cared about
me and they were seeing something that I
didn't see and I Josh and I had to put
on the path on the back burner okay
because it wasn't you know could we have
made it happen sooner yes but it would
have impacted other stuff and as you
said hey a lot of stuff going on
including what we do at Echelon front
Echelon front is my number one it is my
number one and I had to reiterate that
to most of people the reason why I'm
doing my own podcast is to provide value
and bring people into the ecosystem that
we have with Eon front origin Joo Fuel
and yes the other things that I do the
Ministries I help out with you know my
buddies you know Walking In Truth
Ministry those Pursuit events Jesus and
Jiu-Jitsu I'm trying to help but my main
focus is always going to be Aon front
and um and and I think I I share this
with you uh if not well I'm sharing with
you now is I also realized um if
something was to happen to
me what's my family have I mean I know
you and life would take care of my
family I was say you don't got to worry
about no I know I know but but I hear
you the reality of that is at what point
I mean I know I have Investments and
Amanda and I we've been
good stewards with our money God has
blessed us we tithe as an act of worship
and we also are uh trying to be good
stewards with our money in regards to
investing and and and and
saving but if something was to happen to
me what would my family have no my my
wife she's a rock star she's a gangster
she'll make it happen I don't want to
put that burden on her and the kids and
so I I looked at little cattco as
because I knew the intent that Stephen
and his wife Amanda had had was it's a
legacy play you know they're not
building it to be able to sell it now we
all say that and they could hey some
company comes in like Hey we're going to
give you 100 million for it I'm like Hey
Stephen we need to have a conversation
dude you could probably take care of
your family with some of that money yes
yeah my My Equity would probably turn
out to be very well but it
was looking at it from a different
perspective of like hey I love what I do
at ason front I mean you guys provide
for me you guys take care of me and you
bless me for sure and I know you guys
have given me the opportunity to earn it
but I wanted to look at you know these
different things as a hey if something
was to happen to me or let's just say I
couldn't like something happened to me
and I couldn't continue doing what I do
with Echelon front how do I
ensure um
like uh stability for my family like how
do I provide stability for my family and
I said okay well little catco is an
option on the path printing is an option
the investment that I made into Joo fuel
isn't an option other companies is an
option uh and so it's a lot of little
different things that if something was
to happen my family still has stability
to where I'm not a burden like I never
want to be a burden and I've been a
burden in the past because of stupid
decisions and I'll never never I don't
ever want to put my family in that
position again ever Y and so just trying
to be uh diligent and a good Steward of
what God has given Amanda and I and that
was for me little cattco on the
path h I mean without I hope it's very
apparent everything that you guys allow
me to do at Echelon front but then
origin and Joo Fuel and other companies
I've been able to put funds into um you
know for me it's um I just want to be um
a good Steward of what God's given me
yeah well that's freaking of course
that's like uh always got to be a
priority well actually let me take that
back it's not always a priority because
at a certain point we are in life and we
don't have the love luxury of being able
to think that way and you know if you
look at you8 years ago survival you were
in survival mode uh you know that's the
way a lot of people live and so it's
awesome that you can now like look up
look out be like okay and it wasn't an
overnight thing and that's why I try to
explain to other people who are in hard
like tough situations like I'll tell
them I'm like hey you're living my life
that I was live you're living the life
that Amanda and I were living six and
half 7 year goes right now I have
friends right now that are justoo it's
tight and I'm like hey
man keep the main thing the main thing y
don't keep don't get distracted just
keep like doing what you're doing you're
on the right path you know just it takes
time like the what I've been able to do
took time and but it it seems like this
it seems like this CU all like my
buddies my friends that I'm talking
about they remember that they they were
a part of those times and now it's like
hey hey this this took some time and you
and Leif both said that to Amanda and I
you're like hey this is it's going to be
you know 3 to five years grinding it out
we build a team and I built that team at
the fiveyear Mark like we kind of
thought we were and then it's like hey
there's still going to be another three
to five years of grinding it out after
you build the team to get us where we
need to be to where we can be more
strategic and with that with the whole
discipline equals Freedom mindset that
you have and the manual that you gave
Amanda and I were very disciplined with
our finances um you know we we weren't
in a rush to buy a house the house that
we bought it was a it was a blessing for
sure we did it over a handshake with
this guy and it's funny like there's
some things that are coming about that
we're like ah you know we got to work
through these things with this new house
but it's like hey that's just part of
owning a home and we also understand
that it's hey you know what because
we've been diligent with our savings we
can like we're not oh like you got
you've got some some uh Surprises with
the house
Surprise yeah
yeah you know and I'll tell you what
like you know what you're talking about
is like that like that that feeling
creeping in earlier and you know it's
everything that we deal with in life is
spiritual warfare man and you know I I
started to kind of go down this bad
Rabbit Hole thoughts towards this guy
that bought that sold the house to us
because I was like super frustrated with
some of these things that were popping
up and then I had to and then I had to
remind myself of the conversations that
I had with the guy I mean when we walked
through the house they they're playing
praise and worship music and I noticed
that I'm like hey I like the music that
you're playing he goes yeah it's my wife
said if somebody doesn't want to buy our
house because the music then they don't
deserve to buy the house and I'm like
okay that's kind of cool and then the
fact that the guy honored like when I we
we got to the end of the house and I'm
looking at I'm like man this a beautiful
house I've sent you pictures you've seen
it you're like man it's it's amazing and
I remember looking at Amanda and well
cuz I asked the guy I'm like hey what's
the next steps and like we're literally
looking at there's people outside the
gate waiting to come look at it we were
the first people and he said well you
know talk with your wife and if it's
something that you guys think you like
just make an offer this weekend well I
knew the amount of people that' be
looking at this house and I look at
Amanda and she has like tears in her
eyes I'm like I'll get my checkbook
ready for this one and you know cuz we
had lost a lot of houses from out being
out bid and people coming in with cash
deals and I I mean I was talking to you
constantly hey what do I do now and Le
what do I do now and every little black
belt move that you guys had for Real
Estate it just
it just wasn't working and I man and I
both had to understand like okay then
this
isn't this isn't the home that God has
intended for us and what I was able to
do was you know look at Amanda and
realize okay cool she wants this house
and we're talking and I can picture
Amanda just like tear you're like how do
you like it she's just like can't even
talk yeah just tears in her eyes and
she's like it's you and so we you know
talk back and forth and I just it was
cool cuz I just just looked at the guy
and I said sir can I buy your house
which I know is like in real estate you
don't do that anymore what was cool is
he was a listing agent and it was his
house so I was able to have it's just a
unique amazing opportunity he puts his
hand out we shake hands he goes the
house is yours damn now he knew that we
had lost other deals and he said the
house is yours and he goes I just need
to figure out what I'm going to you know
what I'm going to tell these people
waiting out there I was like oh I can
handle that one like just joking he's
like no you know I'm you know I'm let
them look at the house he goes I'm not
going to lose my Integrity over a dollar
he goes this house is yours I'm I'm I'm
looking forward to you like raising your
family in this home so I have to remind
myself of that because if this wasn't
the house that God wanted Amanda and I
to be in he wouldn't have opened up all
these doors this wouldn't have happened
this guy easily could have been like hey
place your offer we'll see how it goes
out knowing and and I'll tell you what
the the vehicles that were parked out
front if that was a representation of
their livelihood and bank accounts I
wasn't playing in that Ro there was
Bugattis out there it wasn't happening
have you seen the lambo SUV yeah yeah
yeah that was parked out there new new
Porsche SUV a brand new Raptor truck I'm
like who is this group of people who
couldn't have played that game but I
just have to remind myself like okay
these things happen for a reason so
while we're working through these little
things you know what's cool is full
circle Amanda today uh people are coming
to check out some of the stuff it's one
of the companies at groundworks just
acquired one of our clients they're
going to come check out our foundation
and the broken retaining wall in front
of the house and we're going to find
some solutions and work through it first
world problems cuz my worst day is
somebody's dream yeah think about what
I'm talking about right now there's a
family listening there's some guy
listening who his family is living in an
apartment which there's nothing wrong
with that been there done that who's
going you know what JP I'd love to be in
that house and I know that and I respect
what you're doing sir I've been where
you're at I'm not saying any of this
stuff to brag or anything else but it's
just just to remind people like hey man
just keep keep keep pushing forward and
I and also as a reminder to myself hey
my worst day is somebody's dream I've
got a I am I am blessed beyond belief
right now yo what's that what's the
swimming apparatus at that thing like
it's like a pool but it's not what is
that it's a spool it's not a spa and
it's not a pool this is what the guy
called it no because I remember I was
like I was like oh yeah was pool and
you're like no it doesn't have a pool
and I was like okay the next thing I see
is a picture of your kids in a pool and
I was like yo what do you what is this I
clearly didn't communicate that properly
cuz actually our real our realtor almost
didn't Renee Powers shout out to Renee
she's phenomenal agent she almost didn't
show us a house because she knew how
small that the body of water was because
we'd go look at other houses they're
like yeah this our pool and I'm like no
that's a hot tub like don't try to S me
that this is a pool if I hey if I'm
buying a house with a pool I want a pool
I want it to be legit and it's just one
of my things I wanted a space for a gym
and a pool I got the space for the gym
it's amazing yeah and um um it's
attached to the guest house which is
crazy it's on two acres um and but the
guy the Dave Who Sold us the house he
just had this like Authority when he
said it he goes and this is my spool I
didn't want a pool it's not a pool but
it's bigger than a spa I called a spool
and I'm like is the water hot or cold
both whatever you choose okay so so it
can be chilling or it can be heated at
the same time is it separate at all it's
just one temperature whatever you want
yeah okay yeah that's cool you had a
couple 20 PB bags of ice from bies it
gets cold quick right it's awesome right
on yeah it's it's red I was uh shopping
for a house years ago and there was a
house came up and I was like bro this is
like tell my wife my wife was like y you
need to like same thing like tears like
you need to make this happen I'm like I
will make this happen so we go look at
it and I'm like yep and I told the real
I'm like hey like we don't need she's
like we you want to think about like
nope don't need to think about it like
we're ready to rock and
roll and they're like well you know like
we're going to show it this weekend and
blah blah blah and I'm like okay well
we'll you know we'll put together an
offer letter and blah blah blah and uh
so then like I get home I write a letter
to the owner of the house you know I
like Google it find out blah blah blah I
write her this letter you know you know
ma'am I just want to let you know we
came and looked at the house it's
incredible and we're from here and we
you know this is I got the kids and we
want to raise them here and blah blah
blah just this really nice you know kind
of uh heartfelt
letter and just you know I would really
appreciate your consideration I'm I you
know I just retired from the military
blah blah blah blah the whole nine yards
and uh they took a cash offer from
someone else I didn't get it that
happened to us literally the week of
this the week of I wrote a letter Amanda
wrote a letter our all of our kids wrote
letters like just I mean you know my
kids were like this is a dud JP's got
his kids writing letters Next Level yeah
they had five letters that came our our
daughters cor Nola Drew pictures of the
house and like all this stuff and I
thought the same thing like that house
I'm like this is and it's still that
place was gorgeous um and it just and
even the owners yep owners told our
realtor they told Renee like hey we
really like this family like we want
this and then whoever it was that came
in and got the house they just came in
with a cash deal and I'm like
congratulations to you yeah
congratulations the the the more of the
story well not the moral but the
finishing of the story that I just told
is that house that I that we had written
these letters and I was like really
wanted we didn't get it and then like 3
weeks later the house that I have oh
yeah so it was just like and CRA it was
you know crazy that that it went the way
it did but it's the way things work you
know yeah and and I even told him Adam
like hey like how much over this asking
price would would you have wanted to go
for us to get the house
and so we were talking about that I'm
like okay so even the repairs that we
have to do MH even if this stuff isn't
covered by warranty which the house is
less than three years old so Foundation
problems guess what warranty 10year
warranty on foundation so we're not
going to come out of pocket it when
groundworks company that they acquired
whatever one in Dallas that we're
working with they come in and they have
to do work they deal with like whoever
did it like we don't have to pay and I
even told her I'm like okay hey because
I thought I was like oh we're going to
have to pay all this stuff out of pocket
I'm like good Lord
and um and I told her I'm like hey even
if we go up to that amount we're still
good and my mindset I was talking we had
a bunch of guys over from church we did
a little Frogman Friday workout at my
house where we just crushed everybody it
was cool they came over they prayed over
the house the property and everything
else like that and we did this awesome
workout and I was talking with one of my
pastors Pastor Drew and I was just like
yeah you know like I don't know what
we're going to do with this I was
explaining I mean you pull up in my
house you see the broken wall it's a bro
it's not cracked it's a broken retaining
wall you see it it's very obvious and
you know a couple guys asked and it
wasn't like that when you bought it nope
damn they stopped watering the month
that they did the lease back I'm not
saying that this is what caused it
however comma like if you don't water
your your property in Texas it dries up
quick and it's going to cause these
issues okay like the retaining wall like
cracked and broke and it just doesn't
matter what we've done like it hasn't
been fixed but yeah there was no issues
when we bought it the month that they
did the lease back they were there they
stopped watering
and then a lot of these Foundation
things started to happen but whatever I
mean they didn't do it on purpose
clearly and I was but I was talking with
Pastor Drew and Pastor Tyron about it
I'm like well you know worst case like I
have some like dude we got a great deal
in the house there's equity in it
already if I had to take out alone I'm
just going to redo the whole retaining
wall and the backyard and create the
most epic backyard pool setup that I
likeed where it's what we want and I
never have to like like cool why would I
take a vacation when I have this setup
you know so so good yeah we're raining
wall broke good good build the backyard
you want when you talk when you're
talking about how much money uh your
wife is willing to spend we kind of had
we were having this random conversation
with my whole family we're talking about
like my dog and like well how much we
cuz one of our friends had a dog get
sick something spend a bunch of money on
it and so the conversation starts
getting fired up with my well what would
you spend what would you spend don't ask
me that question so my wife my uh like
one of my kids what about you mom and my
wife's like I consider Odin one of my
children I was like oh no I was like oh
no like that's that's a big ass price de
bro yeah I consider Odin one of my
children I'm like okay so let's hope
this let's hope this dog doesn't get too
sick or I'm going to be freaking broke
that's what that sucks mine's like
what's the price of a 9 mil
[Laughter]
round awesome I'm just saying like it's
a dog I'm just kidding somebody's losing
their mind over that comment I'm kidding
somebody definitely is you're
kidding check don't watch the Youtube
right now my facial reaction did we what
else we cover everything we up to speed
we got we got the stuff done hey if
people are coming to the muster in in
October and they want to hang out we're
actually doing a Jesus and Jiu-Jitsu
event the Saturday after the muster so
October 21st okay in Dallas this is in
TAS in tahos and it's going to be noi
right on we usually do ghee this will be
noge so it'll be easy for people to
travel with rash guards and shorts and
Banta who is the number one ranked brown
belt in the world it's now a black belt
under joal roacha he's going to be
teaching the semar which is rad where is
it going to be is it going to be where
we do the muster stuff or is it going to
be somewhere else no that would have
been cool but that would have cost us a
lot of money you know we're Ministry we
don't have a lot of money um but it's
going to be at uh double five Mid Cities
so one of the affiliate gyms how big is
double five Mid Cities
uh I'm just thinking that when people
hear this I mean if that's the problem
that sign up thing or all all hands like
hey just show up it's free F JP I mean
cool no that would be hey if we had it
to the point where there's so many
people that we couldn't do Jiu-Jitsu and
we had to rotate people out I mean
that's a great problem to have um I just
I you know I did think about like oh
maybe we could host it hey here's the
deal if I get hundreds of messages on
Instagram and our Jesus and Jiu-Jitsu uh
page gets hundreds of messages then I'll
do something to raise some money to
where we rent out Matt space I we'll
we'll figure out something I don't I
mean who knows if that happens that's a
good problem and we'll work through it
but so free jiujitsu and Jesus seminar
yep October 21st in Dallas Fort Worth
that double five Mid Cities must already
sold out we have the San Diego mustard
coming up it's selling out quick too so
just be advised to that um so cool there
you go JP uh what else we got we got Joo
fuel obviously we got hydrate we got
greens we got Joo go which I've drank in
one and a half at this point in time we
also got uh what else we also got that
new pre-workout the new pre-workout the
new pre look I know you're a pre-workout
guy right let's go and I have now been
toying with it right cuz it's crazy
experimenting with it's crazy it it's
crazy but it's freaking damn dude I only
drank one go during this in case I was
gonna get like a little dry scoop hitter
of that pre-workout D I didn't know it's
it's no joke it's so good um so that's
the we got we got the Pre-Workout that's
out we got Mulk which is a godsend yes
it is where else can you just get 30
grams of protein in less than 30 seconds
yeah less than 30 seconds yeah see and I
did notice that too recently where you
know how like you know I mean I'm sure
you've downed the RTD ones right you've
downed a whole one in one one hit right
okay so I've never done that with any
other protein drink I've done this
probably 50% of the time with this one
for real cuz it's a and I was thinking
oh maybe they're just smaller I don't
know maybe but it's cuz it tastes good
and here's another hack I don't know if
you'd call it a hack but you know how
like after Jiu-Jitsu right you know
you're drinking your water or whatever
you go home and you're like oh I'm kind
of thirsty for like a water or a cold
ice something like this BR try drink a m
it's actually kind of like on the
refreshing side but it's still that
hitter we and I'm going to put Bel
little on blast in the Joo fuel team
will will there ever be a strawberry
RTD uh I think it's on the product road
map but you know what is
coming coffee oh that coffee one I tried
it when we went to the origin Summit
they had it I've told a few people I'm
glad you said it because I've been very
cryptic when I'm talk about it's
probably secret I don't whatever if it
is wait is it coffee coffee or coffee
flavored it's yes coffee flavored with
caffeine and
protein it's like a freaking I'm okay
with
so I don't drink coffee and I don't like
coffee but of course I had to try it
just to see like what the deal is here's
the deal here's the deal so good it do
you know what tiramasu is tasu yeah tasu
is good tasu has some kind of like
coffee in it right there's something in
it that's coffee it's wait what's that
other small coffee called espresso yeah
it's got something like that in it right
tiramasu
this somehow tastes like tiramasu it
taste sweet good so anyways we got that
coming um what else Joo fuel hydrate so
hydrate and I told you this right I told
you my morning routine daily
non-negotiable hydrate creatine if
you're doing a workout first thing in
the morning you add the
Pre-Workout boom report back with your
success you're saying you mix hydrate
pre-workout and creatine all in one
drink if I'm working out first thing in
the morning if I'm not working out first
thing in the morning it's just the
hydrate and the protein
or sorry Hydra in the creatine yeah oh
yeah I'm saying hydrate creatine boom
water money Aiden's been on the creatine
M Train oh yeah that kid is getting big
as yeah he is you're freaking legit I
can't wait this senior wrestling season
like I am so fired up it's on it is on
yeah uh damn oh yeah speaking of hydrate
so I was talking to my daughter my
oldest daughter the other day and like
we were just talking all of a sudden and
she was she was coming home from that's
jiujitsu she's coming home from
Jiu-Jitsu and all a sudden you know I'm
like saying something she goes yes and I
was like what she's like oh I had
hydrate in my bag anything I was like yo
she's like I got that little addiction
when you get done training yes bro when
you get done training and you're just
just sweat everywhere yeah so I also
travel with them because travel
dehydrates me I I think it travel it
dehydrates most people so I always have
one in my backpack in my fanny pack like
I I have a few of those little
individual hitters
just you mix that on the with your water
on the flight and it's kind of a dessert
thing too again like juice it's sweet it
tastes sweet and it's freaking good it's
got and also it's got vitamin C it's got
like 100 milligrams of Vitamin C in it
too so when you're traveling it's like
all good AC crossb anyways there we go
joof fuel.com go check it out go to
Vitamin Shop go to GNC go to military
commissaries AES HB down in TAS thank
you Tas people Meyer up in the up in the
midwest thank you all crushing Harris
Teeter Lifetime Fitness Shields small
gyms uh Jiu-Jitsu
gyms CrossFit Gyms strength and
conditioning gyms just gyms just people
places where people get after it if you
own one of those go just email JF sales
joof fuel.com and we will set up a
wholesale account for you if you go to
one of those places and you want it tell
your tell the owner let's make this
happen so there you go Joo fuel get
better get stronger get faster get
smarter whole nine yards origin usa.com
you need get need to get yourself some
americanmade gear jeans boots I was just
hunting was unsuccessful on my hunt I
did not
Harvest but I had an awesome time I
was so close to Elk cam Haynes had he
killed an elk the elk was two yards from
him what how two yards cuz it walked up
and couldn't see him cuz he's in full
origin Raptor camo two yard two yards
that's you know two yards it's on video
the video is not that great that could
have been an awesome hatchet kill oh it
could have been I it would have been but
it's an awesome kill
anyways uh just freaking epic yeah the
the camera work Rihanna was doing the
camera God bless her she was doing
multiple things she was calling she was
filming she had all kinds of things
going on but it is it is a Savage uh
video and anyways cam hannes Raptor camo
two yards elk screaming in his face
kills that thing just he he said he said
he goes that was in self-defense bro
I would just freaking frontal shot on an
elk anyways origin USA check out the
hunt gear uh Jiu-Jitsu gear obviously
we're doing Jiu-Jitsu get your jiujitsu
on ghee no ghee rashu guards boots
jeans um that's what we're doing all
made in America you're not going to
support communism you're not going to
support the destruction of the
environment you're going to support
Freedom you're gonna support taking care
of the environment that's what you're G
to do
that's what we're doing origin usa.com
go get it RTX gear too by the way oh
yeah you're wearing that that uh thing
right there yeah also the T-shirt the
it's super comfortable but also the RTX
shirt I wear as my undershirt for travel
for Echelon front so it's perfect it's
the black shirt under my Echelon front
Polo um you know it's an
antimicrobial
yeah you said something else but we know
what you're talking about an microbial
microbial
right so it's great cuz then after I get
done I could take off the Polo travel in
it it still looks professional enough
clean enough to it's not it doesn't look
like unprofessional I can get a workout
in there with that same shirt later that
night and it helps with my packing dude
that RTX line is sick the short Anthony
crunk he was at emersion Camp he he
helped as an expert one of my black
belts under formiga I saw him the other
day at the gym and their noi cuz we got
noi pans today and tomorrow in in Dallas
and he's like
I haven't worn any other type of shorts
since emerging Camp these RTX shorts are
incredible so you know what's weird
about the antimicrobial and anti- stink
Funk uh the first like set of RTX shirts
so Pete sends like two to me and two to
Kip and we get them and like three days
later four days later like we're on
three of us are on like a call and I was
like yo my shirt freaking stinks and
Kip's like yo mine is heinous and we
were like and Pete's like I don't know
and uh anyways it turns out the one the
initial ones that they sent us were just
sewn but they didn't have like the
treatment to it and so they just rre bro
I threw it away but that that anti smell
that anti Funk like material or the the
treatment that it goes through is like
totally legit and if you don't have it
you would have a problem luckily we got
it yeah so that's the RTX line anyways
Joo uh sorry origin usa.com get some
Joost store.com named and created by
Echo Charles kinda yeah sure okay what
do we got there uh well you know we're
all representing in our own way oh true
it's true there we go so if you want to
represent the discipline equals Freedom
which is The Roots The Source like JP is
as well go oh yeah we got shirts and
hats and hoodies and stuff like that lot
of shirt Locker reminder shirt Locker
new new shirt every month it's the I I
think it's the only T-shirts my
father-in-law wears my father-in-law
Jeff he he loves all the design I know
I've said this before J Jam dad the same
way Jam's dad is 100% he's just he's a
shirt Locker all day which is awesome
all day hey is is the shirt that uh K
dog was wearing today was that shirt
Locker it said the discipline will not
allow this yeah shirt Locker is that
brand new uh no two months ago okay bro
some people around here don't have that
hey hey some people got it some people
don't you know but hey hey you determine
your own invol you see what I'm saying
yep yep so yeah if you are involved yeah
new shirt every month designs are good
last one
yinyang oh I haven't seen that one
displine Freedom Yin yanging pretty
solid right there actually it's not out
yet it's not the first yet so yeah
actually when this comes out it'll be
out but anyway we'll see people seem to
like the designs what I'm saying so yes
it's on Joost store.com if you like
something go Ahad get something yeah yo
if you need steak by the way you got
some we got some options for you we got
Primal beef.com
freaking legit awesome steak I I must
have had nine of them in the past like
six days yeah I got mine too by the way
so the kid you know you know how it
comes with dry ice right you a lot of
time when you ship dry oh bro the kids
love the dry ice like a potion you put
in the water anyway that aside the hot
dogs mhm bro you can tell when it's like
a sweat shop hot dog and like a real hot
dog a Primo beef.com yeah bro we chopped
it up put in the chili oh man I know how
they do it yeah well I know how they do
it oh yeah the the fruit
finished they got it going on oh yeah
they know so we got Primal beef.com
that's in Virginia we got Colorado craft
beef by the way which is emerging onto
the scene Colorado craft beef another
just
awesome awesome ranch with awesome beef
and we got that working so check out
colal crap beef if if you need beef and
then finally obviously little cattle Co
we got some options for steak
look you need steak you need
steak so that's why you think I'm
involved in some steak I'm involved in
some steak we're eating steak we eat a
lot of steak we're even eating beef hot
dogs now that's what's going down
putting it in chili apparently actually
it bro I I am not really that down for
hot dogs in general not cuz cuz not cuz
they taste bad but just like the I don't
mind the thing the whole thing the whole
idea bro you ever look you know how you
know when they say see how the sausage
is made bro it should be see how the hot
dogs are made bro it's like 10 times
worse and ground beef that's what I've
learned like that's what Steven's
educated me on and and since we launched
little CCO and you know obiously Primal
beef and Colorado craft like if you're
not getting it from these companies like
your ground beef like I would be just do
your research and you know you talk
about what's cool about this industry
when I first talked about little Cleco I
think that was episode
376 um the guys from Colorado craft
reached out to me on Instagram they said
hey if there's anything we can Jeff he
was like Hey if there's anything we can
do to help let us know and I was like
that's crazy it just shows you their
intent and how cool the
agricultural just beef industry is
because it's like hey we're going to
help out and instead of having this
scarcity mindset it's like no why don't
we have the mindset of growing and
expanding like our customer base and our
reach and and people's knowledge of like
hey why it's good to know what's going
into your food and into your bodies and
you're helping Americans you're helping
the small you know the smaller companies
like you order for our company you know
right now like stepen and his wife are
picking it up and his family is at the
warehouse right now stalking the
freezers like you follow us on Instagram
you'll see like his son Brody is
literally going to the freezers and
pulling out the orders and filling them
up it's just it's a really cool thing
you know and Aiden's going to be be
working there this you know in the
evenings in the summer as well once
wrestling season's over well yes that's
his Focus during wrestling season he's
going to be eating he's going to be
consuming yes what we is he doing this
year I don't know man I think he's
what's he walking around at right now in
the 190s damn dude what is he 6'2 I
think he's 6'2 yeah still yeah I don't
think he's hit 6'3 yet awesome 6'2 he
wrestled at 175 H
down decompress let him decompress but
uh yeah the industry is cool and those
guys at Colorado craft I thought it was
really cool how how nice and helpful
they great companies just great
companies doing the right things for
Sean since he launched we launched it's
like hey like we're bouncing and stuff
stuff pass on each other and it's just I
just I love it it's awesome Yep uh so
get your good Stak from one of those
places subscribe to the podcast under
dejo underground check that out Jo
underground.com we we control it so that
way no one can tell us what to do and
look we don't we we don't causing
problems over here but you don't know
what's going to happen so jock
underground.com check that out YouTube
subscribe to all the YouTube
channels uh psychological warfare that's
still in action by the way if you need a
reminder I talked about reminding
yourself there's a reminder for you
check that one out it's on uh iTunes
Google Play are all MP3 platforms what
year did that come out do you remember
16 I think damn dude I was saying I was
going to make another one of those but I
kind of stopped saying but I do owe the
world well I owe some people I feel like
just generally speaking you're uh a lot
of the stuff you say kind I mean it's a
it's a you know it's a hodge podge for
sure but it's uh it can be used for the
same function as psychological warfare I
found okay okay well I like it that's
what we're doing Flipside canvas Dakota
Meer making awesome stuff to hang on
your wall written a bunch of books
obviously leadership strategy and
tactics expanded a dish black cool
looking cover get it order it get this
information that we talked about today
and then all the other books that that
I've written especially the warrior kid
books get your kids the warrior kid
books please get your neighbors kids the
warrior kid books that is going to help
them so much and all the things that you
know you should tell your kids to do and
that you tell them to do and they don't
really listen to you they will listen to
Uncle Jake proven fact proven fact they
don't want to listen to you they will
listen to Uncle Jake so get those
Warrior kid books for all your kids
ashon front you heard to talk about that
today we solve problems through
leadership all your problems are
leadership problems go tolam front.com
come to one of our gigs
that's what we do bring us into your
company and also we have an online
training platform extrem ownership. you
can learn these things that we talked
about today you can learn to utilize
them in your daily life in your family
with yourself with your company with
your business with your pickup
basketball team these principles are for
everything that you do when you interact
with other human
beings when you when you're trying to
build the relationships when we talked
about that we talked about so go to
extreme
ownership. and you can take these
courses online there's free courses on
there by the way this isn't like a big
money grab no we just want you to learn
this stuff it's going to make your life
better yeah so check it out extrem
ownership. comom and if you want to help
service members active and retired you
want to help their their families you
want to help Goldstar families check out
markle's mom mama Le she's got an
incredible charity organization
really helps helps out a lot of people
that JP and I know personally we've seen
it transform them doing Medical
Treatments that the government doesn't
pay for so hyperbaric chamber uh just
incredible support that she gives so
americaas mighty warriors.org if you
want to get involved in that Heroes and
hor horses. org mic aink up there in the
mountains he's up there in the mountain
right now he just got done like skinning
an elk that he killed with a freaking uh
a carved
stick that's what he's doing but he just
got out of the he did just get out of
the field he took two two groups this
this season takes veterans up there into
the mountains where they can find
themselves again and it's it's helped
guys out so much so check that out
Heroes and horses. org also Jimmy May
has got that organization that he
started behind beyondthe
brotherhood. org heck yeah Jimmy May
helping guys figure out what their next
mission is going to be and help them get
into that next mission so there you go
beyondthe brotherhood. org if you want
to connect with us JP is on Instagram
he's on Twitter JP denell two ns2
L's and little story behind two ns2 L's
that's what Stoner told
me I was like I was right I was about to
write your name on something something
and I was like we got denell and he's
like two ends two L's and I I don't know
why I remember that but I just remember
him saying he knew that I wouldn't know
how to spell it yeah and he's like two
ends two L's check so that's why I've
never misspelled your name that's
amazing uh Eko is that Echo Charles I'm
at Joo willink on the social media
things but just be careful because the
algorithm the time waster the the dark
pervert of wasted time is on there it's
in there it's in Instagram it's it's
called an algorithm and it's got your
name and it knows what you're trying to
think about and it's going to intercede
as much as it possibly
can and waste and destroy your life if
it if you let it if you let it it will
waste and destroy your life that's what
it'll do it'll send you from one thing
to the next thing to the next thing to
the next thing hey if you ever gotten
LED out of an Instagram scroll session
have you ever gotten LED out where it's
like hey this just took me to something
that's less interesting than the last
thing so I don't want to look at it
anymore no it doesn't do
that every single thing is selected
based on the way you look at that screen
and how long you look at
something and then it figures out what
can entice you and it shows you like an
AB like it first shows you well maybe
he's going in this direction oh no he's
not he's going oh give him four more of
those this thing is freaking
evil so just just get off of it you want
to check in check in but I'd rather you
don't honestly I'd rather you don't
check in I'd rather you just do more
burpees that's what I'd rather you
do uh JP thanks for coming down thanks
for uh joining us thanks for everything
you've done for me that you continue to
do for me everything you did for the
teams everything you did for our country
and everything that you're continuing to
do now with everything that you're doing
all the lessons that you teach the
principles spreading the principles just
thank you it's uh thank you it'll it'll
always it'll it'll never cease to amaze
me everything that you've done for me
and I appreciate it um also thanks all
the men and women out there who are
serving right now and who have served
and if I might say so we didn't talk
about this much today but I want to give
a special and solemn appreciation to the
snipers and machine
Gunners right which JP was both a sniper
and a machine gunner and our machine
Gunners and our snipers kept so many
Americans alive with their skills and
their ten tenacity so special thanks
tonight to all you pig Gunners out there
and all you snipers in the military
thanks for what you
do and also thanks to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service and all First
Responders thanks for what you do to
keep us safe here at
home and everyone else out
there leadership is hard
life is hard and
making leadership decisions is one of
the hardest aspects of leadership but it
doesn't have to
be it doesn't have to be you can follow
the protocol you can check the list you
can go through the loop you can go to
the book you can refer to the book you
can use the book and this applies not
just to leadership strategy and tactics
Fe Field Manual set up those reminders
So You Don't Stray From the Path
refer back to the things that ground you
as a
person and then detach detach take a
step back so you can really see what's
happening in the world don't get caught
up inside your own head you got to take
a step
back that's what you need to do and keep
an open mind closed minds don't make
good decisions closed minds don't see
the mistakes that they're
making so to detach keep an open mind
and
lead and until next time this is JP and
eeko and Joo out